there's no time o clock hey you guys us
once again yeah episode 189 it's gonna
be a good one good old you you tell them
you tell me I can tell just by static
are going well yeah going back to
Wisconsin for this one you know cuz
remember we did Ed Gein a couple of
weeks ago yeah really weird how
Wisconsin seemed to pretty seem to
produce these kind of mild-mannered
cannibal necrophiles what's up with that
Wisconsin this is one they're gonna be
about Jeffrey Jeffrey Jeffrey never that
guy screeming of did Jeffrey I hate you
Jeffrey I hate you Jeffrey she's
freaking out in the court well yeah
that's my brother yeah there's the
sister I'm just yeah if I wig in the
[ __ ] out oh yeah yeah I'll [ __ ] blame
you yeah yeah there's a if you're
wondering there's it's it's a it's in
most of the documentaries about him yeah
I saw that earlier today
yeah so we're gonna talk about good old
Jeffrey Dahmer the people number those
people here's a wreck man yeah and it's
like he's one of those ones where I'm
not saying I feel sorry for him because
I don't really but some people do and I
can kind of see why he's another one to
that it's like as messed up as his
crimes were there didn't really seem to
be any it's like he wasn't abused he
wasn't I mean he didn't really have
anything in his childhood that would
have made you think that it was gonna go
down that way we killed his first victim
when he was a kid so well he was 18 yeah
but yeah he was in high school what he
did so I met by a kid and just doing
that is enough to probably [ __ ] you up
yeah to have that hanging over you and
then he had these weird sexual fans
yes just he just seemed like a [ __ ]
weird dude all around you I still
haven't seen my friend Dahmer which is
supposed to they supposed to be like a
really good movie it's based on a
graphic novel about a friend of his you
know it's like from the perspective of a
friend of his like in high school but
I've heard it's really good I haven't
seen it yet so you know
well it's we'll see how it goes I
definitely do want to see that sunlight
to see list Oh
oh my goodness Pookie came in those
shoes are not tearing stuff up so before
we get into talking about mr. Dahmer I
think I only have a couple of shoutouts
we have two new patrons this week I
think I mentioned hobo nasty before okay
see you because he was the one that
asked you about the National Guard
question okay sorry he's playing with
the camera yeah and also we have one
named Justin so hey guys thank you very
much thank you very much for your
support any little support you just want
to share videos and [ __ ] like that that
really helps a lot to like and I'm doing
all that crap yeah you guys know how
YouTube works did you have any other
shoutouts he wanted to know not really
now that we got sidetracked show going
you know we can kind of just [ __ ] you
know what I mean
we don't have to keep the audience is
updated as much because we're updating
them because we're updating them like
pretty much every day in real time yeah
so that that does help but it's funny
because when we did the show last week
because we had just started doing like
the sidetrack shows and I was thinking
to myself oh well now we're doing the
sidetrack shows all these like other
random [ __ ] that we're talking about
it's like we probably won't get as many
we won't go off on as many tangents like
on the actual show actual show ended up
being three and a half hours yeah we did
anyway we did it anyway
you know it'll probably happen on this
one can we please have that be the next
t-shirt like just a little 13 o'clock
logo it says Tom's gonna Tom Joe
something in the YouTube comments that I
couldn't remember somebody asked what
the recipe for Google Conn was again
yeah and I said right it's equal parts
tequila
pineapple juice yeah and is it guava
nectar Omega yeah okay I got it right
then yeah yes I
firms that in the comments okay good yes
equal parts of those three you can you
can adjust them to taste if you want to
be stronger you know you can have or to
gala to it and you do that over ice and
now it's good drink yeah and you have
specific types of tequila yeah we want
using it you want silver tequila yeah
but if you don't have that man I like
her Ito's Hornitos is really good in it
yeah we had to get Courtney dose last
time we were at the Sam's liquor store
because all the Sam's brain was gone
yeah although they were pretty well
stocked otherwise actually I hate to say
but we probably should brave the
epidemic and go out we're gonna get
liquor store Marquez I am completely out
I'm out of whiskey I'm out of vodka
right yeah go do that tomorrow alright
so let's start talking about old Jeffrey
Dahmer yeah yeah this is some messed up
stuff he reminds me of Edie gained a lot
just in the sense that he doesn't come
across as someone who's like a sadist
necessarily they just like gain he's
kind of like a product you know product
killer rather than a process killer
pretty much yeah you just wanted that
end product of a body you've been trying
to make a damn real doll this is before
Real Dolls existed yeah essentially
that's he was trying to do and honestly
it's like yeah he was a necrophiliac but
I also feel like he wanted I don't know
yeah I don't know if he necessarily
needed them to be dead you just wanted
them to like not move around them yeah
you wanted him to be quiet and not
interact he didn't want anybody looking
at it it goes back to that same thing
yeah I think they got some dudes that
are just they got so many sexual
hang-ups and they don't want to be
looked at when they're having sex they
don't want anybody to be there cuz they
want to be kind of like masturbation
yeah it's like they want somebody to be
there but not really and they don't want
anybody judging them yeah they don't
want the burden of having to like you
know cater to someone else's sexual
needs as well as their own sense
actually you know I feel like he even
said something like that like word for
word so Oh Jeffrey Dahmer was born in
Milwaukee Wisconsin
in 1960 now his parents were Lionel and
Joyce and as I said he had a really
pretty fairly normal you know life like
a childhood um a little bit
dysfunctional but nothing out of the
ordinary you know I mean no abuse no
nothing like that
he was gay getting rejected though well
that's probably not well not so much by
his family because I'm like that dude
yeah he said that he didn't really
realize you know until he was probably
like 12 13 14 yeah that he was gay he
was kind of I think he was kind of
bothered by it initially but later on
like when he got into his 20s it didn't
really seem to bother him so much
because he would go and hang out with
gay bars and stuff like that and from
everything that I've heard he was
actually fairly popular he didn't really
have much because he was you know a
nice-looking dude kind of and um so he
didn't really seem to have all that much
trouble in getting people to like come
back to his place with him yet I
remember although some of them he did
like you know say he was gonna give him
money in high school he was trying to
hook up with guys though and he was
failing yeah I ever met to it um yeah I
don't know I didn't really hear that
much about that but he battled that
first one yeah well that was just a guy
that he picked up right that what he
didn't know was that that was a guy from
school no no no he was working out with
him no that wasn't no he just picked him
up he was a hitchhiker it was all
remember still no that's not he yeah he
was just a random dude gonna confused
with something else yeah I thought he
took a dude he was working out with some
dude I think it was thought he went to
high school with that guy no okay no
killed him and then crushed up his bones
with a hammer well he did do that but
it's like that it was yeah it was it was
a guy he didn't know him okay just
picked him up hitchhiking but yeah so um
so his parents like you know they they
wanted the kid he was their first kid
and you know he seemed like a really
normal like happy baby
his dad was kind of like away a lot
because he was studying for his PhD his
mom had some mental issues in the sense
that she was she seemed kind of like
high-strung kind of
like attention-seeking kind of needy
type of behavior and stuff like that but
like I said neither one of them were
abusive or anything like that and he was
um a pretty normal kid like up until he
was about six years old so we'll get
into that in a minute now his um his dad
Lionel actually wrote a book later on
where he kind of talked a lot about
Dahmer as a kid and everything and he
said you know some stuff that that
Jeffery did as a kid you know it it
didn't seem weird at the time because it
seemed like [ __ ] that other kids were
doing which it was but then in light of
what happened later he's like now I look
back and see it and it seems really
strange and everything like that because
he said one incident that he remembered
he's like so when Jeffery was four years
old his dad was apparently they I guess
there were like all these little bones
of like little animals like underneath
the house like I guess like a cat had
killed the birds or something like that
so there are all these bones under there
and the dad was like cleaning it out now
the dad was a scientist he was like a
chemist and so he like knew about like
acids and dissolving things and like how
to bleach bones and things like that and
he said that Jeffrey was like when he
was four he was really really interested
like in these bones like he was
fascinated with like all the bones and
like the noise they made like when they
dropped in the bucket and everything
like that he was in the anatomy yeah he
was like really really interested in
that stuff which when a boy is four
years old that's not that weird
I mean I've known like a lot of little
kids I have brothers and it's like you
know I've known other little kids you
know my parents ran a daycare for a long
time like other little boys they like
gross things and they like a love dead
[ __ ] that's what I mean they like [ __ ]
like that so it wouldn't have raised any
eyebrows at the time cuz that's pretty
common and he was pretty little I think
I told a story you know growing up in
the 70s me and all my friends from my
block you know we were maybe ten between
that eight and like 10 maybe 11 around
that age we would go down railroad
tracks with sticks and [ __ ] and look for
stuff that had been hit by the dam yeah
railroad you know by that by the Train
you'd find dead dogs out there and just
you know eventually we outgrew it
yeah that's what I mean I see something
was gross steak you know yeah it over
[ __ ] all the gas hit you need [ __ ]
magazine he's vomited throwing up that's
what I might horse me another man
[ __ ] but it's just you your kids kids
are just a little boys are like a couple
steps above a dog and they like grocery
love gross [ __ ] and they [ __ ] run in
packs like little dogs and dogs would
join us sometimes we run around dogs and
get involved too yeah you know we're jet
you know you're heard of you ever heard
of West Coast Choppers right Jesse J
yeah well a lot of that was over there
that's in Long Beach Carson area and
where his shop is is where we were
playing yes that's the railroad tracks
rabbi Dominguez elementary school okay
that's what that's where it was yeah I
think it's all built up now it's it's
and I think that's now according to the
photos that's where Jesse James's studio
is now Bob it's behind where Dominguez
elementary used to be yeah but where his
shop was we had an adventure pretty much
before they built that industrial park
we found a huge stack of white buckets
they were sealed plastic buckets this
must have been stacked eight feet high
must been 40 of them out there man we
were so curious so we knock some of
those buckets off and we worked for
about a half hour trying to pry the damn
lid off the top of that bucket and man
the smell just just [ __ ] white slop
came out of it and we just immediately
gagged and threw up and there was bones
and [ __ ] you know what it was what's
that gallons and gallons of rotten fish
heads and fish guts oh boy if somebody
had put in plastic bags and then put it
son put inside those damn plastic but
it's a and they dumped him out there you
know it was a illegal dump yeah yeah
like hey it's had a bunch of dumb little
boys are gonna come along and open this
up and once they get a surprise it came
from some kind of fish butcher shop
somewhere and that's because there was
enough of him to where that came out of
some kind of factory
that's pretty core somebody shake
somebody's butcher shop yeah man and
[ __ ] my friend Bobby now I've already
got some of it on him man he [ __ ]
steak the whole [ __ ] day he had to go
back home [ __ ] change his shirt yeah
I'm just a [ __ ] bleach bath
I'm sure his mom was super excited
having to like do that pop creepy is
that it was white with yellow [ __ ]
tinge to it but not yellow orange yeah
orange highlights that's what rotten
fish heads in the heat in the summer
heat that's that's what it turns into
yeah at least it did that night anyway
yeah yeah so that's what I'm saying so
even the Saudis dad didn't think it was
weird at the time he just thought oh
cool you know my kids like interested in
science or he's interested in Anatomy
maybe he'll be a scientist or something
like that that's not turned out he was
only four at the time um at this point
like you know as I said he had been born
in Milwaukee but they actually moved to
Iowa when when he was fairly young
because his dad was going to college
there he was studying for his PhD so now
when Jeff was six years old he it was
found that he had a double hernia which
seems a little weird for a six-year-old
but you know it happens so he had to get
surgery now
strangely according to his family it
seems that after he recovered from the
surgery when he was six years old he
really wasn't the same anymore and I
don't really know if it had any fit was
just a coincidence or if something went
wrong with the surgery I don't see how a
hernia surgery could mess up your brain
because that's where your hernia is yeah
it could be but I mean according to his
family according to his dad I really
like that they said after he had that
surgery when he was six he'd been like a
real outgoing like happy kid completely
normal they're like after that he
started getting a little more they said
he wasn't real confident anymore he got
really really shy really um you know
introverted which he hadn't been prior
to that he didn't want to go to school
he didn't want to like you know he
didn't like to be around people like it
seemed to stress him out like he had
like all this anxiety and stuff so they
said that he you know he hadn't been
like that at all beforehand but then
after that he kind of started going in
that direction and that's kind of the
direction that he continued going in
after that so you know that seemed a
little weird
so 1966 Lionel had got his ph.d and he
got a job as a research
chemist and this was in Akron Ohio now
at this point Joyce the wife the mom she
was pregnant with another kid and this
kid was born and his name was David they
actually let jeffery dahmer name the kid
because he had been getting like I said
he'd been getting so isolated and
introverted and shy and everything they
wanted to kind of try and involve him
back in the Family Circle and everything
so they you know gave him you gave him
the task of like giving his brother a
name so there's a couple pictures of him
as a little kid like holding his baby
brother so like I said he just starts
getting more and more introverted until
at times it's like he was just like you
know he was just answer questions with
like a single syllable and [ __ ] like
that so other than the surgery his dad
thought well maybe it's because we moved
to Ohio from Wisconsin like maybe
because we pulled him away from
everything that he knew and his little
friends and everything and you know he
didn't really get over it and his dad
said to he's like you know I was kind of
like that when I was a kid you know what
I mean he's like I was kind of shy and
introverted and everything and I got
over it so he probably will too maybe
it's just a phase that he's going
through so he was like he seemed like he
was um you know keeping an eye on the
situation but I guess it wasn't super
alarming or or unusual enough that he
you know wouldn't need to go get any
help or anything like that so in 1967
they bought a new house and Jeff action
Jeffrey seemed to actually get a little
bit better he kind of struck up a
friendship with this kid named Lee and
you know was doing a little bit better
in school seemed to like you know
associate with his teachers and things
like that now apparently he um he really
liked this one teacher that he had I
don't know if it was math teacher I
can't remember what subject she taught
but for some reason he thought I mean he
was a pretty little kid so he brought
her a present which was like a bucket
full of tadpoles mm-hmm which you know
well she he was a little kid and she was
like oh thank you so much and everything
like that now he found out
though that she had given the tadpoles
to his friendly and that really made
Jeffrey very angry because he felt
betrayed because like hey I gave you
those and you were supposed to keep them
so he goes over to Lee's house he finds
the bucket of tadpoles and He pours
motor oil in it and he kills all of them
so he yeah um he was only seven years
old at this time but you know that's
still kind of messed up so you know as I
said he's getting more he it's not even
a sense of him just getting like more
shy and everything like that they said
his whole like physical you know aspect
change like his whole demeanor changed
it's like he used to be you know kind of
a fun bubbly kind of you know moving
around kid and everything like that and
now he seemed like really stiff like
they said he stood really stiffly and
you know and he barely talked and it was
just like this really really weird
transformation and it's like sometimes
he would just like sit in his room and
like stare at the TV or sterols
dead-eyed stare you know what I mean so
it definitely does seem like something
it was something half of that energy
maybe hat like maybe physically happened
too because that seems a little extreme
for just like he's upset about a move or
something like that I mean that
definitely seems like something got
broke and there's maybe he had some kind
of weird reaction to that anesthesia
[ __ ] up his brain chemistry or
something that's maybe it maybe it like
damaged a certain certain parts of his
brain and like made him conscious he was
only kind of like semi-conscious or in
an altered state of consciousness
something like that yeah because they
said he just got real like he wasn't
even in there like he would just sit
there and like kind of stare off into
space for a really long time yeah it
sounds like damn something that
anesthesia would do to you and yeah yeah
it's like I hadn't really thought about
that but I'm like yeah it's probably had
just do something with that I mean like
I said according to his family they're
the one who gave him a bad batch
anesthesia yeah knocked his brain up so
around this time he's getting into like
his teenage years and stuff like that he
took to his dad didn't know this at the
time but he had actually taken to like
kind of riding around on his bike or
walking around the neighbor
whatever and he would collect like dead
animals in garbage bags yeah and then he
would take him home and like strip all
the flesh off and like bleach their
bones and like he had to like keep a
collection you just wanted to keep a
collection of like all these bones and
stuff now it has been suggested and this
is very common with serial killers
obviously that he tortured animals but
that does not seem to be the case other
than killing the tadpoles yeah um they
said he actually had pets that he liked
he had a dog named frisky and he loved
it and everything like that so it's like
they don't think that he killed animals
he just liked to collect dead animals
and like see like take them apart and
see what was in there you know what I
mean yeah so like I said that seems a
little less it's still weird but it's
less alarming he's not counting on me
just dinner yeah he's just finding
roadkill and like you know well yeah and
like taking him apart and stuff yeah so
fascination with the internal workings
of creatures that's yeah it definitely
does seem that that's like what he was
doing so at this stage it seems like
he's a teenager he's not really even he
just seems like he's drifting through
life like a zombie it's like it's not
even he's not even like fighting with
his parents or anything like that
because he just didn't seem to care
about anything he just seemed really
like you know what I mean just
lackadaisical and talked out about stuff
now right around the time he's about 14
years old he admitted later on that this
was around the time that he started
having sexual fantasies about men and
also fantasies about killing men and
were rendering them unconscious and
raping them is what he initially started
thinking about this was also around the
time that he realized that he was gay
obviously so one of the first incidents
that he could remember from this time
period when he was about 14 years old
was he developed a fascination with this
guy in his neighborhood who he would see
jogging every day like he would be
jogging past his house or in the park or
whatever like nearby so he took to like
hiding in the bushes and like watching
this guy jog past
every day and he started having
fantasies that he was gonna like hit the
guy in the head with something and knock
him out and then he was gonna like lay
next to the guy and like jerk off or
rape the guy right so that was his thing
and he did this for a while and then one
day he decided he was going to do it so
he hides in the bushes he has like a big
baseball bat or something like that and
when this guy comes by he's gonna hit
him and then he's gonna do all this
other stuff and for whatever reason that
guy did not jog that day hmm so I don't
know if he just thought oh well that's
the end of that because I said he's just
kind of like abandoned that plan like
after that happened but he was
supposedly gonna do it and I was like I
wonder if that guy knows about that how
close he came to I don't know he made
that up yeah I don't know I'm just
saying you know the thing about Jeffrey
Dahmer is that when he got caught he
readily confessed he did not yeah you
try to say he didn't do anyone I'm an
attention seeker he liked the attention
well another thing too is that he
thought that he knew what he had done
was terrible and he thought he should be
punished for it
he didn't really like you even later on
when he was in prison he got stabbed and
[ __ ] like that well you know but even
before he got killed but um he didn't
like protest or anything because he just
thought he deserved it
right you know I mean kind of committing
suicide yeah so you know so when he's in
high school it seems like he wasn't um
bullied or anything like that he just
was seen as kind of like an oddball like
just one of those kind of weird it
wasn't a STONER but that type of guy who
was always he was kind of known mostly
for pranks like pulling weird pranks or
like just doing weird [ __ ] he was like
one of those dudes that you know
everybody would be in the classrooms and
everybody would be really quiet and then
he would all of a sudden run screaming
down the hall like fire drill fire drill
like he would do [ __ ] like that yeah and
it got to a point where if anybody that
pulled like a goofy stunt like that in
the high school it was called doing a
Dahmer you know what I mean so like
everybody knew about like what a weird
goofball this guy was also when
was 14 he started becoming an alcoholic
yeah several yes several people that
went to school with him they interviewed
like this one girl that sat next to him
like in some of his classes and stuff
said he would just come in with like a
[ __ ] cup or a thermos or whatever and
it had [ __ ] scotch in it 14 yeah I
knew guys like that yeah they never
recovered yeah he was he was that kind
of guy so he was just always drinking at
school all the time starting from a very
very young age
um but he did like he wasn't complete he
was like a pretty average student they
said he was actually pretty smart you
know had an above-average IQ he just
they they said he's smart but he just
didn't like really apply himself he was
just kind of like one of those bones
like yeah whatever I was he was like a
burnout motivated right um and you know
obviously he was drunk all the time but
he was he played he was like played
tennis he was on like the tennis team
like I think he was on the yearbook
staff or you know we worked for the
school newspaper or something like that
so he wasn't like a complete you know
nonentity like he was kind of and he had
a prom date like a girl and everything
like that and he went out with her a
couple times and all this other kind of
[ __ ] another thing that he would do this
is kind of [ __ ] up but I guess some
the family either I can't remember if it
was like a family friend or somebody
that worked for them or something like
that and he had cerebral palsy and
Jeffrey used to do an impression of that
guy and that's something that he would
so he would act like someone with
cerebral palsy like at school and just
do that kind of thing and there's
several people that went to school with
him were like yeah we remember him doing
that stuff I guess well some people
thought it was funny there's you know
they remember it a long time ago yeah so
um so around the time that he was
getting ready to graduate from high
school
his parents relationship had been
deteriorating as I said there wasn't I
don't think there was any physical abuse
or anything like that but they just
weren't really getting along they were
fighting a lot and other kind of [ __ ] so
when Jeffrey was almost 18 years old his
parents
divorced now because Jeffrey was 18 or
nearly so there wasn't any question of
like a custody battle or anything like
that however his brother David was still
young and there was a brutal custody
battle between the parents for custody
of David now in in the midst of all of
this you know brouhaha
everyone kind of forgot about Jeffrey um
because they were busy divorcing and
like fighting over the other kid and
everything like that so what ended up
happening was that his dad left to go
like stay at a hotel for a while like
because he was I think he was dating
someone else by this point or you know
or something like that so he goes to
stay at a hotel the mom takes David and
goes to like another city like to stay
with relatives for a little while and
they leave Jeffrey in the house by
himself
yeah that's weird but I guess they still
paid the rent or was the house I guess
well because well yeah they're not a lot
of in pain I mean the dad came back
later um you know what I mean he came
back to the house later on but he was
left there by himself for a while like
almost like they forgot about him and he
did say later that this during this time
period he felt like he was really like
neglected and they just like forgot
about him because they were so busy yeah
yeah yeah yeah they all just like took
off in like other directions how long he
was in the house by himself it wasn't
that long I think it was days weeks
years I think it was a few a couple few
months actually I think but you know
correct me if I'm wrong now it was sure
how old again was he he's about 18
that'd be weird it would be you be in
your family house Nelson they all leave
and they're all gone this is you in
there that's what I think it's like that
for some reason that really struck me
where you're strange I mean even though
18 you're technically an adult bio to be
like your family moved away and then
you're in the house it'd just be a weird
I just kind of left you there and that's
honestly how he interpreted it and like
they just abandoned him there which they
kind of did I mean when you think about
it so shortly after this happened and
shortly after he graduated high school
in the summer of nineteen
seventy-eight this is when his first
murder took place after right after they
left him in the house by himself which
probably shouldn't have happened so he
picks up this guy who's hitchhiking
this guy's name's Steven Hicks who was
also around a 17 or 18 years old Steven
Hicks was hitchhiking to a concert I
don't know a band it was but for some
reason like Jeffrey was able to kind of
pick him up he gave him a ride part wait
he's like oh come back to my house well
you know have some beers and you know do
whatever so they had some beers
apparently they had sex
consensually and then Stevens like yeah
man you know I got to get going because
he wanted to go to this concert he was
like really excited about it and he
wanted to leave Jeffrey did not want him
to leave so he picks up a ten pound
dumbbell yeah hit him on the head from
behind with the dumbbell two times and
then which knocked him out then he I
guess it says he strangled him with the
dumbbell so I'm guessing he took the
dumbbell and like pulled it like up
around his neck like that like until he
didn't breathe anymore like that so yeah
so he strangled him to death then he
took all of the victims clothes off and
stood over it and jacked off on there
you go the next day and then he just
looked I guess he just left the body
sitting there and then the next day he
took it down to the basement and cut it
up and buried what was left in a grave
in the backyard and then later on like a
few weeks later he went back in there
dug up what was left took all the flesh
off dissolved the flesh and acid and
then flushed it down the toilet and then
took the bones and crushed them all with
a sledgehammer and scattered him in the
woods so that was his first murder no he
didn't do another one for a really long
time it was like a decade what I think
it was nine years something like that it
was Africa out of services I mean he did
other [ __ ] in there like in the interim
like lesser crimes but
that was his first one and they actually
didn't find out about that until much
later on
so let's spooking maybe so org to me
it's kind of he decided wasn't gonna do
it for a while yeah I don't know her
again he probably thought he's never
gonna do it again yeah you don't really
know what's going on and she got worse
later on and then he went back to it so
six weeks after the murder Jeffrey's dad
Lionel comes back to the house with his
I don't think it was his fiancee so I
guess is he hadn't married the new wife
yet whose name was sherry and they came
back and I guess they were surprised to
find Jeffrey living there by himself I
think that they were under the
impression that the mom was still living
in the house but she had left so
apparently there was some communication
lines had been broken they weren't
really keeping track of where one
another was cuz I guess they were
fighting right so I guess they one of
them was assuming the other one was
still at the house with Jeffrey and like
neither of them were so the dad seemed
very surprised that Jeffrey was there by
himself
so Jeffrey decides he's gonna go to
college or his dad made him go to
college I'm not really sure I've seen
I've seen things that say both things so
he enrolls at Ohio State University he's
gonna major in business however he only
went there for one term and he was drunk
pretty much the whole time hmm
they're like he barely showed up at
class
he failed almost all of his classes
they're like the only one that he did
well in was one called riflery which he
got to be on she's a rifle shooting
rifles I guess he was good at that yeah
all the other classes not so much yeah
they said that he just like I said he
wasn't dumb he just didn't really use
you he didn't really give a [ __ ] he
didn't really want to apply itself and I
was thinking when I was reading about
this I know this is like a really weird
and creepy thing to say maybe but he
reminds me of a guy I knew in high
school that we kind of hung out with he
was not exactly what is it he wasn't
weird as this guy obviously but he it
was the same kind of vibe and that
I actually ended up shooting himself hmm
a few years later like after high school
hmm because we thought we had hung out
like a whole bunch of us by accident or
on purpose purpose yeah so I bet ya
remember my other friend like calling me
and tell me about that I think it was
four or five years after high school we
found out about that but he kind of
reminds me his personality is kind of
similar but not he's it wasn't as weird
so so his dad like won while Jeffrey is
in college sort of his dad shows up at
the dorm or wherever he was staying and
he's like basically he goes in Jeffrey's
room and there was just like [ __ ]
empty liquor bottles just like all over
the place and it was just like a total
disaster now apparently the dad had paid
for him to go like either that whole
year like the whole term or whatever but
because he had just like flunked out the
first term like Jerry's like well [ __ ]
it it's like he just left and didn't go
back so he was only there for like three
months now at this point his dad like I
said now some people have blamed his dad
it's like oh you need they neglected him
and all this other kind of stuff but it
did seem like his dad did know that
there was something going on with the
kid and was like trying to help him out
you know what I mean there's only so
much you can do
I remember the interviews after he got
caught and everything other dad the dad
seemed all rightie
he did he seems like an okay dude he was
like trying to understand he goes well
you know he's mentally ill that's yeah
big time yeah but yeah so at this stage
it's January of 1979 and his dad is
basically like well you flunked out of
college it's like you can't just lay
around the house you have to either get
a job or go join the army so Jeffery
goes and joins the army now he initially
trained as a medical specialist at Fort
Sam Houston in San Antonio Texas and
then he got shipped out to West Germany
where he served as a combat medic yeah
now he actually did pretty good in the
army starting out like they said he was
you know average above average soldier
he seemed to get along well with people
however
the drinking was still a problem now for
the first year it didn't really seem to
be a problem and he seemed to be like
enjoying himself maybe getting his life
back together but then the drinking
started interfering and [ __ ] like that
and later on it came to light that he
allegedly raped two men while he was
stationed in West Germany yeah they were
German guys no they were in his yeah
there were other soldiers that were like
stationed with him yeah he's like they
don't do anything about it
yeah that's the thing like he drugged
them apparently he drugged him and raped
him and then but they like remembered
and enough you know and one of them was
raped like multiple times like over an
extended time because they were like
bunking day there they were stationed
together now both of these men I can't
remember their names are like I saw one
documentary that said what they were
both of these men claimed that they had
reported this [ __ ] at the time but that
nothing was done about it
either they weren't believed or there
was just no further like follow up on
that's [ __ ] hot that's not the army I
knew yeah but then there was [ __ ] like
that kind of happened yeah in a unit I
was in and that that dude [ __ ] brand
new private everybody drunk off their
ass up in Korea
alright [ __ ] NCO who was new fishie
[ __ ] [ __ ] call this private
in there planted a big old kiss on his
[ __ ] lips and [ __ ] and that [ __ ]
private ran out of there went right back
over to his copy and told us like a
squad leader yeah and the whole [ __ ]
a whole [ __ ] regiment the whole
[ __ ] battalion was [ __ ] up drunk
you know yeah that dudes whole [ __ ]
chain-of-command like [ __ ] five of
those [ __ ] squatters went down there
and beat that dudes ass yeah MP's got
them all rest of them they [ __ ] tried
him and [ __ ] [ __ ] nothing happened to
the dude they couldn't prove the heat
did anything you know right but the the
NCOs that beat that dudes ass they a lot
of them
not all of them lost their careers but a
couple of you know they all had to do
stockade time yeah
yeah be dead using this might have been
a situation where it was reported but
because there was no maybe no physical
evidence or it was just like their word
or something and they did you know just
both of them said that nothing was
really done about it or that they
weren't really believes yeah but those
dudes were [ __ ] furious they didn't
give a [ __ ] about any UC mga or anything
like that they were drunk at the time
they were just like [ __ ] you did that
to one our soldiers there's a brand new
kid yeah they went in [ __ ] that dude up
yeah and I'll tell you this a dude did
it you think yeah he was sketchy yeah I
can imagine any names yeah yeah probably
better not to don't put Tiger King no
you did it yeah but yes so because he
was pretty much at this stage Jeffrey
Dahmer's like drunk all the time he'd
been in the service for two years but
they were like look your your drinking
is interfering with your ability to do
your job now he was discharged honorably
they didn't really feel like I think
they said like in the in the report or
whatever that yeah he drinks a lot in
stuff but we don't think that the
problems that he's having the military
are gonna be a problem when he gets back
into civilian life so they just gave you
an honorable discharge ah which if only
they'd known so he gets sent when he
gets discharged they sent him to Fort
Jackson South Carolina where he was
debriefed and then they gave him a plane
ticket and to anywhere in the country so
because he had not only flunked out of
college but he had also gotten sort of
kicked out of the army also he didn't
want to go back to Ohio to live with his
dad and stepmom because he was like
embarrassed he was like a shame that he
had failed again so he went to Miami
Beach for a little while now he actually
did find a job there he worked in a deli
like a sandwich shop and he started
living in a hotel that was close by the
restaurant however because he was still
a drunk and he spent pretty much every
extra penny on
boos he didn't pay for the hotel room
after time and they kicked him out of
there so for a while he was homeless and
kind of slept on the beach while he was
working at the deli so finally he after
a little while I guess he couldn't
really take it anymore and he called up
his dad and said hey you know can I come
back and live there and the dad said
that he could on the condition that you
know he actually looked for work and he
actually like do chores around the house
and not just like lay around being a
useless bum
however he gets back to the house he has
not stopped drinking at all two weeks
after he arrives back at his dad and
stepmoms house he is arrested for drunk
and disorderly fined $60 given a
suspended 10-day jail sentence now
during this time period it does seem
like his dad was trying to you know get
him to stop drinking but it seems that
he was unsuccessful in that regard and
after a while the dad and the stepmom
now apparently the stepmom was kind of
at her wits end which you know you can
understand that this isn't even her kid
and it's like she's dealing with this
well he's even not even a kid anymore
he's like 20 at this stage you know and
he's just laying around the house like a
drunk weirdo so finally the dad and the
stepmom are like okay well why don't you
go live with your grandmother the
grandmother lived in West Allis
Wisconsin and the and her and Jeffery
seemed like they were pretty close you
know what I mean so they thought maybe
she could straighten him out
now it did seem to work for a little
while
I should note he moves in with his
grandma and he went to church with her
he did he helped her out around the
house he actually did like go out
looking for jobs and [ __ ] like that and
mostly behaved himself although he still
kept drinking even though she didn't
like it he actually ended up getting a
job in early 1982 as a phlebotomist in a
blood plasma Center in Milwaukee and he
worked there for almost a year but then
he got laid off and then after that he
around for two years without a job and
kind of just sponging off his grandma
like she would just give him money every
now and then now right before he got
laid off he was arrested again this time
for indecent exposure
apparently in August of 1982 he had gone
to Wisconsin State Fair Park and exposed
himself to about 25 women and children
like in a big crowd so he got convicted
he got a but all I got was a fine $50
see it's like it just seems like he did
like all this I mean yeah he murdered
somebody okay already but it just seems
like in the interim like in-between the
first murder and then it was a long time
before there's a second one but there
were just so many little incidents and
like little red flags which at any point
if he had been stopped or hit if he had
been arrested or placed in jail for like
a longer time then maybe like all the
subsequent murders would not have
happened I mean this dude killed 17
people he killed 17 people you know I
don't think it was exactly the same guy
who killed the first guy than that of
the 17 think there was like a pause in
between it's like a change I think yeah
I think he killed the first one and
didn't like it and then tried to hide
the fact that he did it and he probably
went into denial then tried to
rationalize why I did it justify it and
he's like I won't do that again
yeah so then he's experiment with these
other ways of trying to [ __ ] get off
but then as his life declines he gets
worse and he goes back to killing people
yeah but I think it's it's different
yeah it definitely does seem like the
motivation was slightly different
because of what he was doing with the
bodies later on he would didn't do that
to the first one it was like it was it's
like he evolved into a new killer yeah
very different kind yeah and you know
I've listened to interviews with like
child soldiers and stuff from Africa and
how you can get a kid
to in turn him into just basically a
serial murderer and they would just do
weird [ __ ] with them and like you know
you go into a town or to a village and
you want to recruit from that village
and it's kind of like an enemy village
it's what you do is you go in there and
take over and get some kids and say we
can we're gonna kill all of you you know
but we'll let you go if you kill your
parents you can join us so get a kid to
kill his own parents yeah and then
afterwards they say only a weak man only
a weak man would have killed their own
parents they would have rather died
didn't killed the rope so they use the
guilt of that first right
all right they're like we're gonna teach
you how to be strong so you don't have
to do that and what the report is is
that the first time you kill somebody
you get this kind of weird [ __ ]
numbness to it but then it wears off and
you start feeling guilt but if you go
out and kill again you can reestablish
that numb feeling where you're not so
every time they kill a new person it
kind of erases the feelings of all the
people that you've killed preceding that
one yeah
you don't talk that ya can picture what
I'm talking about that and I think
that's I think certain serial killers
kind of have that so I think what
happened was is the first one he killed
probably shocked him but it [ __ ] with
his mind caused him to decline and
eventually got so bad he went back to
killing in order to erase all the deaths
that he had already caused yeah in other
words like going into it headfirst is a
way to conquer that feeling of guilt
yeah I think you know if that make sense
to you yeah that's how it yes yeah I do
I definitely do think that that's
something like that went on because it
does seem like a very long latent period
which is unusual I bet you a head he'd
not killed that first one he never would
have killed those other ones yeah
probably not
um although get BTK did that though
didn't he there was like a big gap in
the there other ones have had that but
it's just it's usually that's pretty
unusual so in January of 1985 Jeffrey
Dahmer famously
gets a job as a mixer at the ambrosia
Chocolate Factory in Milwaukee he worked
on the night shift now he says that
right around this time that he got this
job there was like a seemingly minor
incident that happened that seemed to
like reawaken all of his kind of like
weird sexual proclivities he says that
he's in the West Allis Public Library
like reading a book or something
and he says this guy who he didn't know
like walks through there and like throws
a piece of paper like on his book book
are like on the table that he was
working on he like opened it and it was
like essentially propositioning him for
a [ __ ] hey want to come in the
bathroom I'm like who knows that
libraries were so scandalous Grindr back
then I guess yeah so apparently
according to him it's like he didn't go
but just getting the note was kind of
like a sexual thrill and it got him kind
of like thinking all about those
fantasies that he'd had was it when he
was a teenager about like wanting to
dominate somebody and like having them
be unconscious and all this other kind
of stuff so kind of like brought all
that [ __ ] back up to the fore that's
what he says anyway so so he kind of
started going and putting himself out
there like going out and hanging out in
all the gay bars like in Milwaukee you
know hanging out in the you know it's in
the scene you know he's like going to
the bathhouses and all that other kind
of stuff so he kind of gets known around
the scene looking for his own personal
Rob Halford I guess so yeah so he's like
going out and about at this stage they
also think that he stole a mannequin
like a male mannequin from a store and
was like using that like you said
essentially like a real doll yeah and I
guess his grandma found it later
awkward Blake found it in the closet and
made him get rid of it which I don't
know if she knew what he was doing with
it or if she just thought it was weird
that his I know whatever
oh yeah probably not so so he starts
going to all these bath houses which in
the 80s you know we're pretty
you know you basically went there to
[ __ ] back rooms I mean yeah this was
I mean AIDS was a thing but I feel like
this was kind of like the last that
maybe the early times of it or maybe the
sort of trailing off I'm not really sure
but he says at this point so he starts
having sexual encounters with people at
these bath houses which are consensual
but then he starts thinking to himself
that you know what I'm having sex with
these guys I don't really like the
moving around that they do it's really
annoying right so concentrate yeah
concentrate
[Laughter]
so initially he starts drugging them
like he starts roofing them and you know
having sex with him while they're
unconscious now he did this probably
about a dozen times one of the
bathhouses before the kind of word got
around and everyone found out about it
and he started getting like his
memberships revoked like it all the
bathhouse and he started getting kicked
out of him right he wasn't like allowed
to go back in there because they found
out what he was doing so then he starts
like picking dudes up she was just like
rolled everyone she's so weird so then
he started to go into these places
picking these up and take into the hotel
rooms and doing the same thing like
basically Roofing them and sexually
assaulting them while they were
unconscious so then he starts thinking
he's like okay well that's kind of
awkward then he had a thing where he
read about this 18-year old boy that had
died I don't know how he had died but he
had died recently and they'd buried him
and he got the idea in his head that he
was gonna go dig that body up and take
it back to his house and like do stuff
with it and he actually went to the
cemetery with a shovel and everything
but apparently the ground was really
hard and it was like take you know it
was like too much work it was yeah I was
like taking too long and he was just
like yeah [ __ ] that so I I guess maybe
that it's like well I was gonna like dig
up a body like again but that was too
hard so I guess maybe it's easier to
just make your own bodies yeah maybe
that's what the [ __ ] I don't know
you dig down and find that casket how
are you gonna get that casket open in
your sealed in their dark spackled shut
that's what I mean in some places I
don't know about Wisconsin or Ohio or
anything like that but some places they
actually put the coffin like underneath
like I saw was like a like a slab like a
concrete slabs you get no concrete over
the damn coffin yes you can't get in
that was but he didn't even get down in
there but he had the idea and he went
there with the shovel and everything
like I said some Ed Gein [ __ ] right
there ed could get it done somehow well
I guess they yeah well he was like a
skinny old man yeah maybe they don't
bear him that deep where he was a long
time ago so maybe the standards weren't
as good yeah maybe they were just like
crappy like wooden coffin he was wearing
New Hampshire Wisconsin like I said
Wisconsin Wisconsin that's right the
hell's up with all you necrofear
necrophilia accent Wisconsin there
nothing else to do or what [ __ ] going on
in Wisconsin it's like [ __ ] weird so
August of 1986 Jeffrey Dahmer gets
arrested once again for masturbating in
front of two twelve-year-old boys he was
a near that the Kinnickinnic River kid
in a candy river whatever it is no boys
went running well I think from what I
heard I don't know if this is true or
not but I think that the boys were just
like whatever
I think they weren't even like scared or
anything she's like whatever mister yeah
um now he admitted first that that said
he was that that's what he had been
doing when I got arrested but then later
he was like no I was just peeing and I
didn't know anybody was watching me
right so that they downgraded the charge
to disorderly conduct yeah and he
actually at this point he got the one
year of probation that's all he got and
he had to go to like mandatory
counseling yeah which I presume he went
to although I never hear anybody talking
about it
you know what I mean he had good a
mandatory mansplaining
necro splainin the knick resplendent
they're explaining to some man yeah
so yeah this is like [ __ ] but like I
said it's he's doing this kind of crap
and like yeah he's getting arrested but
he's just getting slaps on the wrist and
yeah they're sending him to counseling
but doesn't really seem to be doing
anything and it just seems like yeah so
you're worried about other things at the
time I guess so
so the probation ends a year later less
than a week after the probation ended he
took his second murder victim yeah this
is 87 so this has been like I said I
think it's about nine years there's a
nine-year gap between the first one
Stephen Hicks days this is the year I
graduated from high school yeah I just
started high school this year idea so
his second murder victim
this happened on September 15th 1987 so
Jeffery is in a gay bar in Milwaukee I
believe called Club 219 and he starts
talking to this other guy in the bar
whose name was Stephen to owe me now
they hung out for several hours together
and we're kind of chatting and getting
to know one another and everything like
that and they eventually leave the bar
together and they go to a hotel and you
know they get a room in a hotel now
Jeffery later said that when he first
took Stephen to the room he wasn't
intending to kill him he was just gonna
do the whole drug and rape thing which
also not good but he said he wasn't
planning to kill him I don't know if
that's true or not but that's what he
said but he says what ended up happening
was that yeah he gave him the drug and
everything and then the next morning he
woke up and Stephen - oh me was lying
under him on the bed and his chest was
all crushed in and he was all bruised
and he had blood coming out of his mouth
and Jeffrey had like [ __ ] bruises all
over his fists and stuff like that is
that he had beaten the guy to death
I am bi and he said that he didn't have
any memory of it and that he couldn't
believe that he had done that although
later he said maybe I was trying to get
his heart out of his chest
I don't buy that [ __ ] but he says he
doesn't remember but like I said some of
the stuff you have to you have to like
realize that he pretty much readily
confessed I think they didn't have to
like ask him about nothing as soon as
they arrested him he was just like very
forthcoming about all the [ __ ] that he
had done and he didn't really seem to be
like exaggerating or making things up or
anything so just sounds to me like he's
trying to push the responsibility of how
he became a a serial killer by you know
I mean he's just trying to he's just
trying to kind of say it was an accident
yeah although like I said the other ones
he didn't yeah I became it I became a
serial killer by accident I didn't
choose this that's what it sounds like
he's trying to do yeah maybe I think
that I think so although although the
first murder he didn't say that that was
an accident he did he said that he did
that he pretty readily admitted that one
I just think that he's trying to make it
look like it was an accident that due to
his own master machination
he's trying to explain it in a way that
makes it good for him I guess it's
through his thought process I think yeah
so it's hard to [ __ ] beat on somebody
and try to kill him and get their get
their heart out of their chest without
you knowing that you're doing it yeah I
mean you know how many drugs are they
taking I don't really know I mean that
you know the victim was drugged I'm
assuming well in the thing about Jeffrey
Dahmer too was that he was a real bad
drunk um so maybe he was just blind
drunk and he and he admitted that a lot
of times like even though most of the
crimes he did say that he remembered
them and he remembered exactly what
happened but he did say that he would
often drink a lot like before he did
them you know what I mean man if I were
to drink a lot I just like to go to
sleep yeah I don't know how these dude
can remain standing well I
well if he's if he started drinking
heavily at 14 I guess you'd be kind of
in or to resist I guess so because it
could be blind drunk it's still walking
around still walking around and light it
killing people because you don't usually
hear that you don't hear much about
serial killers drinking to excess and
then committing crimes you think you had
to be pretty
sharp yeah you'd think that and for him
to have gotten away with it for so long
you know how I am if I get drunk where
I'm really drunk I'm like now I gotta go
home well yeah it's just a lot of times
just makes me sleepy yeah I see it
but yeah so he says that he wakes up and
the guy's dead and that he hadn't
intended to kill him and he's not really
sure how it happened but then he
realizes well [ __ ] I'm in this hotel and
I have to get rid of this [ __ ] body
so he leaves the body in the hotel room
he goes out and buys a big huge suitcase
umm stuffs the body in there I don't
think he cut it up or anything but he
just like stuffed into this big suitcase
then he gets a taxi and takes the taxi
back to his grandmother's house with a
[ __ ] body it's okay Sam and change to
Grandma's house yeah it takes it to
Grandma's house takes it to his room in
the basement cuts the body up puts the
pieces in garbage bags and puts the bags
out on the curb and that working out by
the - indeed we have talked about this
before now yes because other killers
have done that it's like it seems so
seems like Suzy and stupid and you're
also kind of ballsy I guess in a
horrible what evidently that's a very
effective way well yeah because then
they can't really I mean I don't know
about nowadays but they can't really
trace it back to you it's like once it
gets to the dump it's not like anybody's
gonna be alone okay I did if in that bag
there's other bears other [ __ ] that
hazard would start your name on it again
yeah obviously don't do that don't
Lizzie me giving advice to like hey if
you're gonna kill somebody and your
man's out on the curb make sure your
[ __ ] phone bill isn't in there next
to it so they know who you are
Rodya but yeah so apparently this did
work so he just put the cut up body out
of the thing now one thing about this
because a lot of the people that he
killed he killed in his grandma's house
now his grandmother I'm not sure how old
his grandmother was at the time I don't
know if she was retired or she was still
working or she like was out flitting
around like visiting friends or
something like that how do you murder
like sixteen dudes at your grandma at
your grandma's house and she goes
know about it some weird [ __ ] I mean it
apparently she didn't know I mean yeah
he was down in the basement and [ __ ] but
I don't know he killed him there at the
base of an attic at the [ __ ] yes a lot
of them he did yeah and just process the
body there he killed him there so yeah
sometimes that's some weird [ __ ] hmm
grandma must have been one it just like
sits up there and watch the television
doesn't walk around that maybe that's
yeah here we can't hear real well maybe
that's what it was I mean I'm not
blaming or anything like that I just
think it's very weird to have somebody
like murdering people in your house and
you not know about it okay so looks like
we're about at the hour mark so I guess
we will pause here for a short break
commercials kitty videos that type of
stuff I made my drink already
editing magic editing magic so yeah we
will be back in just a few minutes to
talk some more about Jeffrey Dahmer cuz
we saw a lot of victims to get through
cuz he killed a lot of people you guys
so we'll be back in just a couple
minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you love true crime I love true crime
and I've spent the last three years
compiling a series of the most
intriguing unsolved murders of the 20th
century it's called the faceless villain
and volume three is available now
featuring such fascinating cases as the
Caddy murders the carry baby's case the
Frog Boys the al-qasr murders and the
inokashira park dismemberment incident
the faithless villain volume three is an
involving exploration of unsolved slang
spanning the years from 1980 to 1999
pick up your copy and print or eBook
formats on Amazon or download the
audiobook version from audible.com and
get ready for a chilling journey through
modern crime history
all right we're back talking about yet
another Wisconsin weirdo Jeffrey Dahmer
yeah so following the murder of Stephen
- Oh me it seems as though I guess in a
[ __ ] up way that you know kind of the
gloves came off after that point because
I guess that Jeffrey decided that he
liked it he could do it now and it's
like so he just started you know whether
or not he had intended to kill Stephen
to a me or not at this point he very
much made the decision that he was going
to basically start trolling for victims
specifically to kill them and do things
with their bodies you know what I mean
so you know at this stage this is kind
of like where his iconic whose mo kind
of like came into play so two months
after he killed Stephen Thome Jeffrey
Dahmer comes across a 14 year old
prostitute named James dock stator now
he offered this kid $50.00 to pose for
naked pictures so he lures the kid back
to his house has sex with the kid and
then he drugged him and strangled him
this is again in the cellar of his
grandmother's house he actually left
this see this is what's killing me what
I was talking about before like how the
grandmother didn't know that this was
going on
this fourteen-year-old kids body was in
the cellar for a week before he cut it
up damn maybe she wasn't real able maybe
she couldn't get down into this either
that or she was out a lot I was like I
don't really know how you could how
could you hide a body in the cellar your
grandma's house and then be able to
sleep at night I'd be like man she's
notified that's what I mean it's like I
don't know like did he hide it do you
leave it laying in the middle of the
floor me no see but he couldn't have
left in the middle right I mean a week
is a long time and it's like you know
I'm sure she came down there but so he
left it down there for a week then he
cut it up pretty much the same way he
had done with his first victim he kept
the skull like he kept the head
then like he boiled the head and boiled
the skull and like kept the skull for a
little while but then he ended up
pulverizing it the rest of the body
parts he put in garbage bags and put out
in the curb again and didn't get caught
again so you must been boiling the head
at his grandmother's house and her in
her [ __ ] pots that's one thing while
she was there as she I don't know when
she was like eating on that [ __ ] Oh
Geoffrey what are you making in there
yeah it smells good no it's fine it's
like I just I I sure hog head cheese
yeah that's is that what he said now did
he have like some fun excuse yeah yes
dad it's like there's so many there's so
many jokes about cuz I was watching like
a bunch of documentaries boxed I've
heard some Jeffrey Dahmer jokes but
because you don't give a [ __ ] you can
just do whatever you want
I can't it's like a cloak of
invisibility cuz you don't give a [ __ ]
yeah he did yeah he didn't really see I
mean he seems concerned about getting
caught in the sense that you know yeah
he was cutting up the bodies of like
disposing of them cuz you don't want him
to be found but then he didn't really
seem that concerned about it because
he's just leaving bodies laying around
for like a [ __ ] week before he do oh
I'll get around to that maybe he
secretly wanted to be caught and stopped
I think he did because even when they
caught him um he was kind of like yeah
you know he kind of fought him for a
minute but then he was once they figure
that was funny funny copy yeah yeah
pretty much and it's like he I think he
said when they arrested him something
like I deserve to die for what I did or
something like that so March 24th 1988
Jeffery meets his next victim who was a
22 year old man named Richard Guerrero
and he met him outside a gay bar which
was called the Phoenix now he also
offered this guy money I don't think he
asked him to like pose for pictures or
anything he just said hey I'll give you
50 bucks if you like come hang out with
me or like come keep me company or
whatever so once he gets him back to his
grandmother's house he drugged him with
sleeping pills and then strangled him
with a leather strap and then performed
oral sex on the corpse damn left the
body there for about 24 hours then cut
it up and he did the same thing as he
had done with the 14 man way he cut the
body up he put the body parts out on the
car
he kept this skull for a little while
and then for some reason pulverized it
and scattered the bones
imagine he's given he's blowing this
dead dude right a dude pass a boner
wouldn't you [ __ ]
that dude him freak out yes that's what
I mean it's like thinking about this
kind of stuff it's like who was wrong
with this dude that's what I mean it
it's like it's so weird because like
when you watch cuz there's all kind of
interviews with him and simply because
like I said he was very forthcoming
about the [ __ ] that he did and he knew
it was bad like he knew it was wrong but
it's almost like he couldn't stop
himself but it's just like watching him
he just seemed so normal you know what I
mean
not really he seemed to be kinda normal
to me he never seemed normal to me he
seemed [ __ ] creepy yeah but not as
creepy as like some other ones like on
the scale of creepy he seems like one of
the less creepy ones to me he seemed
pretty [ __ ] creepy whole situation so
now on this one here was a guy that was
one of the luckiest guys on earth
April 23rd Jeffrey Dahmer lures another
guy to the house using the same ruse he
gives him a cup of coffee that has a
bunch of sedatives in it and he's
presumably planning to kill this guy but
then the grandmother comes partly to
partway down the stairs I guess she had
heard him come in or something like that
she said something like hey is that you
is are you home Jeff or whatever and
Jeff tried to be like yeah it's just me
I'm down here all by myself not anybody
with me nope no siree you know kind of
like that like that kind of thing yeah
but apparently the grandmother saw the
other person I don't know if she saw him
like his face or just saw that like
another set of feet or something like
that but she saw that there was another
person that he had brought somebody home
so at this stage Jeffrey was like well
[ __ ] I can't kill this one now because
grandma knew that there was one in the
house but he had given them him the
drugs so what he did was he waited until
the drugs worked and like the guy went
unconscious and then I guess he took the
guy to the hospital and like just left
him there weird I don't know if he just
like left him outside or if he just went
in there and said hey this guy like oh
dude I don't know who he is by and then
like took off I'm not really sure
how that went down well yeah so that guy
got away I don't know what his name is
but yeah yeah that's like the luckiest
dude ever so September of 1988 finally
the grandmother finally tells Jeff hey
um how about you move out of the house
because one you keep bringing all these
Rando dudes home in the middle of the
night and also the basement really
stinks yeah as it would like she didn't
think Oh dead body smell I don't know
what she [ __ ] thought you know what
I'm saying
granny wasn't too with it I guess not
he's bringing all these dudes over here
and it stinks down here yeah it's like
you think I'm with the tit you would put
two together like out yes you don't want
to think that your grandson is a serial
killer
but there comes a certain point where
something you got to get on the clue bus
you know what I'm saying so he's able to
find a one-bedroom apartment and he
moves in on September 25th now the day
after he moved into this apartment he
lures a 13 year old boy to his house and
you know by saying hey I'll give you
money if you pose naked for photographs
and he drugged this kid and sexually
fondled him yeah
he didn't kill him though because he got
I guess he got caught so he gets for
this he gets convicted of second-degree
sexual assault and I love this enticing
a child for immoral purposes all right
so yeah so he gets convicted of that but
they said that they weren't going to
sentence him until later you know I mean
it was like some and while they while
they were doing that like while there
was a gap they were just like letting
him run around loose yeah so you just
don't report back for sentencing yeah
yeah so that's what he did okay so he
gets convicted and then even like two
months before his sentencing hearing he
murdered another person like he was
supposed to like in too much she's
supposed to go back for sentencing but
he murders somebody else yeah he don't
give a [ __ ] that's what I mean he just
really doesn't and and like you said I
think he's almost kind of like hoping he
gets caught like that someone else will
stop him because apparently he's not
successful at stopping himself from
doing this [ __ ] so the next person he
killed
was a 24 year old man named Anthony
Sears he also met this man at a gay bar
in March of 1989 he said that when he
was at the bar in this pretty wasn't
trolling this particular time however he
did a little bit of victim blaming cuz
he said oh well this particular guy like
came up to me at the end of the night
and started talking to me and like
hitting on me and stuff so he figured
hey might as well kill someone I wasn't
planning to but here you are
now see into the black guys yet yeah
these are all black guys a lot most of
yeah most of the because the early
victims were white um or I think the for
the 14 year old prostitute boy he was
Native American I believe and some of
the later victims like the yarn kids I
think were Laotian but yeah most of his
victims were African American that was
just he liked how it looked better he
said yeah he had that was like he had a
say like their black eyes like that
muscle definition yeah so so came a
whole bucket of dicks underneath his
damn [ __ ] bed yeah - yeah yeah all
kind of Knicks games feet [ __ ] a dick
heads
Dixie heads in a refrigerator we're
gonna get to it yeah bucket of dicks oh
my goodness somebody needs to like I'm
bang called then yeah so he does the
same thing with Anthony Sears he lures
him back to his grandmother's house even
though I think that he well I think what
happened I think he moved to an
apartment and then he moved back to his
grandmother's house and then he moved
out again you know what I mean cuz it
like during this time period is there
was a lot of moving around going out so
he did the same thing he drugged the guy
and strangled him now again this is at
his grandmother's house so the next
morning he takes Sears his body puts the
body in his grandmother's bathtub and
cuts the head off and then attempts to
skin it like take all the flesh off of
it where the [ __ ] is grandma during
auditions see this is what I'm wondering
where is grandma grandma must bend semi
senile or like I said or maybe she was
just out all the time maybe
wasn't home maybe you know what I mean
like maybe I make chai he was making
time she'd go and he's like okay now sir
oh now it's time to do it yeah that's
what I mean she's gonna go out to like
some church function or some [ __ ] like
that cuz she was like a churchy lady so
maybe she was always I never occurred to
him what if she comes home early like I
said it did really like he gave much of
a crab maybe she would just swarm those
ones I was just sitting a damn recliner
right in front of a [ __ ] TV listen to
cars and all [ __ ] day or whatever
yeah and he could do whatever he wanted
sure there wasn't paying attention he
just kind of had guts you know he had
balls
he'd be in a bathtub for a couple hours
are you doing in there yeah the baths
Africa playing a corpse grandmother some
weird [ __ ] this [ __ ] up yeah yeah so
he takes all the skin off the body he
like pulverizes the bones he through the
bones and most of the flesh away however
because he found Anthony Sears
particularly attractive he was very
attracted to him this was the first
victim where he decided he wanted to
keep some of his body parts like forever
like some of the other victims he had
kept their skulls like for a little
while but then like later he had like
crushed him up and threw him out but he
thought he thought that Sears was so
beautiful that he decided he wanted to
keep parts of him like indefinitely so
he kept the guy's head and his genitals
and he kept them in acetone and he put
them in his locker at work kind of the
Chocolate Factory yeah yeah again so you
can open up Mars in there yeah some
weird [ __ ] and your [ __ ] that's like
keeping like body parts in your [ __ ]
office drawer like you work it [ __ ]
you know main like some [ __ ] office
so that's crazy like right next to them
you gotta have [ __ ] balls man that's
what I'm saying it's like I'm not saying
that's not a good way it's not admirable
I'm just saying here that are you just
dumb as [ __ ] or he just didn't get I
don't think he gave a crap honestly
right so you got to be dumb as [ __ ] made
to think that well the management will
never come through down through here and
[ __ ] do a check and go hey look a
severed head and a dick if I didn't kill
him longer than I had his head in the
[ __ ] jar back at the [ __ ]
workplace and in the locker I couldn't
lay up in my bed [ __ ] go sleep I'd be
thinking man but that janitor it's
[ __ ] open up that's my meat you it
would be on your mind just all the day
yeah all the time
see this is why I would make I would
make a terrible murderer because I was
just being like [ __ ] what I was
worried about all the time the color
they found that head and they're closing
in on me any minute his way their bed
yeah but it doesn't really seem to
bother him like whatsoever I don't think
he was too much of a thinker probably
not so yeah so he's keeping this poor
guys like head and genitals in his
[ __ ] work Locker and he left them in
there for like a year like until he like
moved to another apartment and then he
took them with him to the new apartment
he never got caught for that had him up
in every room there was a [ __ ] head
damn in a locker in a chocolate factory
[ __ ] bizarre it's [ __ ] crazy
so finally Geoffrey goes to get
sentenced for that sexual assault thing
that he did on the thirteen-year-old kid
he got five years probation and one year
in the house of correction and he got
like a work-release he also
significantly he had to register as a
sex offender now sadly here's another
thing where it seemed like they did the
right thing yes he should register as a
sex offender because this was you know
he had had several offenses of this type
even though they hadn't caught him for
the murders yet but then later on when
you know he got caught for other [ __ ]
like or you know when he gets famously
caught for that like fourteen-year-old
kid that's like wandering around naked
in the street yeah Oh what is nobody
checked if he was on the sex offender
registry nobody checked all you had to
do was run his name and it would have
come up it was harder back then wasn't
good what it wasn't this computerized
problem like in the cops man
I'm really mad at the cops in this
[ __ ] case I'm just saying
particularly those two cops
so he gets paroled after a little while
and he temporarily again moved back to
his grandmother's house and then he
moved into his probably his most famous
residence which was Oxford apartments
yeah
now yeah this was like um it was kind of
a shitty neighborhood but it was like
real close to his work and the apartment
was like super cheap it was like $300 a
month and that was like with all the
utilities except the electricity - yeah
sounds like yeah well it's like well
what would he care it's like he's
letting bodies rot in his [ __ ] house
there's maggots on him and [ __ ] it's
like I'm sure a little Roach isn't gonna
bother him so he moves into his
apartment very famous apartment 213 and
he takes the mummified head and genitals
from the work locker and you know puts
him in there he had only lived in this
new place for a week before he killed
his sixth victim Raymond Smith who was a
32 year old male prostitute again he
offered him $50 for sex
same thing gave him a drink that had a
bunch of sleeping pills crushed up in it
and then he strangled him now at this
point it seems like he wanted to not
only keep the body parts but he wanted
to start documenting the victims and in
various poses and in various stages of
dismemberment so the day after he killed
this one victim he went and bought a
Polaroid camera and started taking a
bunch of pictures I was watching I've
seen most of these photos so I said yeah
I have to and what well what ended up
happening was I was watching I watched
like a shit-ton of like different
documentaries and I watched this one
that they didn't warn you that they were
gonna show you like the crunchy version
I mean so I'm just watching it and
they're showing the regular photos that
I've seen all the time and I was like
holy [ __ ] okay I just I wasn't expecting
it
I saw him back in the mid-90s after I'd
gotten out of the army I first started
[ __ ] running on the Internet it's
must been around 96 or so 97 some of you
old-timers back from the old the old
interwebs means the whole [ __ ] mutt
remember the original internet that
[ __ ] was [ __ ] fire
they had a [ __ ] scene called they had
a they had a they had a site called core
gallery got comm and you could go there
and they just had all kinds of crime
scene photos and and though stuff that
had been leaked you know and they had a
whole Jeffrey Dahmer section I saw the
bucket of dicks I saw the [ __ ] dudes
that were got caught it cut up in the
bathtub and he was doing for the
headless bodies and stuff his [ __ ]
his arm yeah there's nothing like 97 I
guess well I'm gonna tell you like I'm
not gonna put him in the video just
because I don't want to get well this is
probably be like slightly or limiting
trying to do anyway stick to man yeah um
yeah because I saw some of the pictures
that he took that he posed like headless
bodies and stuff like that if you want
to see them you can go to murder pedia
which is which is a good site because
they usually they they have like not
just serial killers they have like
pretty much all murderers and it's like
everybody you can think of mostly and
they compile all different sources kind
of like in one place they'll have like
the Wikipedia article they'll have like
an other like book excerpts and stuff
like that and then they usually have
photo galleries so in the Jeffrey Dahmer
one there is an extensive photo gallery
that says you know warning graphic these
are all the crime scene photos live but
if you want to see them you can click on
it I just it surprised me because I was
just watching this video and it seemed
very normal and then all of a sudden POW
right there like severed head like
headless body and I was like okay that's
a lot I also saw a photograph of
drawings that he was making of a damn
altar that he was yeah yeah he was gonna
build an altar with a bunch of skulls
and like skeletons on either side and he
even had like he wanted these kind of it
wasn't like a disco light but it was
kind of like these [ __ ] blue lights
and it was crazy
yeah I saw the [ __ ] thing yeah he
wanted to like sit there like in of
leather throne or so I can
of all these BOTS all these skulls BGK
shoes like with his [ __ ] supervillain
layers well I got crap yeah this is
crazy
so yeah after he's taking pictures like
polar polaroid pictures of Bremen
Smith's body and like I said I saw one
of them and it's pretty [ __ ] gross
because it was like he never had any
like trying to be sexy with the dead
body
yeah it was [ __ ] up yeah so then he
took a bunch of pictures and then he
takes the arms the legs and the pelvis
and he boils them in this stuff called
soil X which I guess is supposed to like
some kind of acid or it's most like
break down the flesh or something like
that so then he rinses the bones out in
the sink and took the rest of the
skeleton he took the skull because he
wanted to keep that but the rest of it
he like put it in this big fat that he
had like full of acid like to dissolve
it and he takes the skull and he likes
spree pieces he's like decorating the
[ __ ] was like Ed Gein she liked building
furniture or the [ __ ] yeah like what
the hell is the matter with you so he
put it like in this he had this filing
cabinet with this stuff and he was like
keeping it next to the other guy's skull
cos he was saving him up like I see like
you said for the altar you had to make
an altar yeah so he was like trying to
get a certain amount so about a week
later he picked up another guy however
this guy got away because what ended up
happening was that I guess the drinks
got switched so Jeffrey Dahmer actually
ended up drinking the [ __ ] with the
drugs in it
dude I see yeah that's what I'm seeing
this product I'm probably told the
princess princess bride it's like you I
think this poison is in this Cup yeah he
pulled was maybe right because that guy
ended up like stealing a bunch of [ __ ]
from like Geoffrey's he stole a bunch of
cash and everything I'm gonna say white
dude like [ __ ] he tried to [ __ ]
roofie me I'm on [ __ ] take your [ __ ]
yeah he did he took like a watch $300
yeah it was clothes and stuff yeah yeah
um not surprisingly Jeffrey Dahmer did
not report this to the police although
he did sell his probation officer about
it if he had been robbed so June of 1990
his next victim was 27 years old his
name was Edward Smith again he lured him
to his apartment and then drugged and
strangled him
now apparently at this stage I guess
that Jeffrey was not happy with how some
of the acid and the bleach and stuff
like that was making the skulls brittle
and he was trying to like experiment
with other methods for maybe making them
longer-lasting and stuff like that so
this guy like after he like rendered him
down to a skeleton he put the skeleton
in the freezer for like a really long
time because he wanted to see if it
would like suck all the moisture or
something I don't really know why um so
no it didn't well yeah he was just
trying different things out like for
whatever reason it didn't work in case
you wondered however he was kind of mad
about this because he wanted to dry the
skull out because he was going to keep
this skull - and he put it in the oven
and it blew up hmm so he was really
upset because he ended up and he even
told cops like after he got caught then
he felt particularly bad about this
murder just because all of like the body
got ruined and he couldn't keep any of
it yeah did it all for nothing yeah
that's essentially what what he was
thinking yeah yeah it's [ __ ] up so
then almost three months go by before
his next one this next one was a 22 year
old guy named Ernest Miller same thing
he offered him $50 this time I don't
know if he like approached him on the
street with this because this would seem
kind of weird but he's like hey I'll
give you $50 if you let me listen to
your heartbeat and listen to your
stomach gurgling which I by I did don't
buy it I mean I know that some people
have weird things and it's like you know
what I mean you know how sometimes
people can like sell their used panties
or like where they call it a MSR yeah
yeah MSR or like you know the those
dudes that'll like give you $200 for
like hey send me a video of you stepping
on something in high heels or something
like stepping on jelly and stuff it's
like whatever whatever floats your boat
man but yeah so he says he'll give him
$50 if you let me like listen to your
chest and everything so then he gets the
guy back to his apartment he's
apparently listen it was hard or
whatever and then he starts trying to
like give him a [ __ ] and the guy's
like hey you know that'll be extra yeah
try to get a freebie at which point
Jeffry drugged him now because yeah well
because he only had two sleeping pills
left I guess he hadn't stocked up on his
supply so it didn't quite like knock him
out so he didn't strangle this victim he
actually cut his carotid artery which
was the same knife that he used to cut
up the other victims so this guy
actually bled to death he was not
strangled you know and then he did the
same thing again he like posed the body
like took a bunch of polaroid pictures
puts it in the bathtub and starts
cutting it up and he said that he cut
off the head first and then he was like
talking the head and like kissing the
head and stuff like while he was cutting
the rest of the body yeah like hey he's
like crazy so this guy he takes like his
arms like his biceps and some of the
skin off his legs like chunks of flesh
off his legs he takes his heart out and
then he puts them all in plastic bags
and puts him in the fridge because he's
gonna eat him later yeah this is I think
this was the first cannibal thing
well why wasted he's hungry right yeah
well remiel out of this [ __ ] yeah and
well his thing was his idea was that it
you could kid would be part of him what
the victims would be yeah we'd be
replenished by eating this and [ __ ]
now he's party and ever yeah yeah so
that's basically what's almost goes back
to instant primal [ __ ] warrior [ __ ]
eatin people's hearts and their livers
to get their [ __ ] warrior essence you
know yeah except what this guy it's all
sexual and [ __ ] yeah and it's like be
with me forever
yeah he definitely did seem to have some
kind of weird like he wanted a companion
that would never leave yeah and so if he
had to like eat them or took their head
or whatever then he was gonna do that
yeah so but I think this is the first
guy that he actually like eight parts of
em I could be wrong about that but yeah
so the rest of this the rest of the body
he like boils it in the soil X and then
he put the skeleton and the bleach and
he also this was another skull where he
like painted it like he had the head and
he like painted it put an enamel on it
so if he was like experimenting with
different like preservation techniques
like to see what would last the longest
so then three weeks later he picks up
another guy at 22 killings but that's
what I mean this is a lot of people yeah
he picks up another guy 22 year old guy
named David Thomas and he picked him up
at a mall this guy he just said hey want
to come back to my place for drinks he
was apparently like pretty charming cuz
he was able to like get people to come
you know and most even like a lot of the
people like after they knew that he had
done all these horrible things even all
the like a lot of the psychologists and
you know cops and stuff like that that
interviewed him said that he seemed real
affable like he was real friendly real
he seemed like a nice guy yeah but you
know he wasn't so yeah so he says hey
want to come back to my place for some
drinks he's like hey maybe if you want
to pose for some photographs I'll give
you some money or whatever so then he
drugged the guy now this guy I guess he
got him back to the place and he decided
that he wasn't into him like he wasn't
attracted to him and but then he thought
well I already knocked the guy out and
you know gave him the sedatives and if
he wakes up he's gonna be mad so I guess
I better kill that man so he says but
only being practical yeah but he didn't
keep any of his body parts because he
didn't find him attractive like him
right even though it's weird because
like I'm looking at pictures I'm like
he's a probably good-looking dude I
guess but you know some bad the guy
something about the guy he didn't like
particularly so he did kill him just so
he wouldn't like get upset like so he
wouldn't wake up and get mad at him but
he didn't keep any of his body parts
although he did take pictures of him
like kind of himself like cutting the
body
but everything like that um so then it
was like kind of a gap of about five
months although they do think during
this time period that he did try on
occasion to like lure people back to his
apartment but was apparently
unsuccessful or decided to you know not
do it like once he went through it or
whatever so he was still going to his
parole officer at this time and
apparently reported that he was feeling
like really bummed out really depressed
anxious that he had been considering
suicide all this kind of stuff but he
didn't kill anybody during this time
period and then came February 1991
Jeffrey sees a 17 year old guy named
Curtis Trotter who was standing at a bus
stop near Marquette University now he
pulled the same ruse he said hey if you
pose naked I'll give you some money and
also sex so he did the same thing he got
the guy back to his place he drugged him
and strangled him with a leather strap
and cut him up and he kept the skull the
hands and the genitals and photographed
each stage of the dismembering hmm
because he just wanted to remember it I
guess a little less than two months
later this was April 7th of 1991 he met
a 19 year old guy named Harold
Errol Linds Lindsay who was walking down
the street this guy was actually not
gated and pick him up in a gay bar or
anything like that he was just a random
guy that happened to be walking by like
running an errand or something but he
was able to lure this guy to his
apartment drugged him and this is the
first guy where he attempted to make a
zombie is what essentially he was doing
he would drill a hole in a dude's head
and then he would pour various things in
there usually like Murray attic acids
with his boiling water sometimes
hydrochloric acid because he thought in
his addled brain that it would make he
didn't think it would kill them he
thought that it would make them
completely subservient like like a
zombie like they would do whatever he
said yeah well he had done some like
studies of anatomy yeah he tried to
figure out what
areas of you know of the brain control
what he thought if he could destroy that
area
he could make a person into basically a
living zombie yeah and a living sex doll
yeah it didn't work no not at all
nope no and what ended up happening in
this situation I believe he put he
injected hydrochloric acid into his
brain after he drilled a hole in his
head
and he did that and then the guy woke up
and he said I have a headache and then
he said what time is it and Jeffrey
Dahmer like freaked out and drugged him
again and then strangled him again yeah
so he caught that guy's head off and
kept the skull also and he actually this
guy he took all the skin off and
attempted to like preserve it you know
what I mean like he put it in salt water
let's dry it all out so he would keep it
but it didn't like last very long like
it started getting all yucky and brittle
so he ended up having to throw it out
which he was bummed out about now as as
you will probably not be surprised to
hear but so 1991 the other residents of
the building since an apartment building
y'all like other people lived around
there and there were other apartment
buildings around there they started
complaining to the building manager
there like you know there that apartment
213 like really smells bad and you
really have to see what's going on and
people also complained about noise
people said we'll be here like a bunch
of knocking around and we heard someone
running a chainsaw yeah repeatedly in
the middle of the night again put two
and two together people you hear a
chainsaw in the middle of the night you
hear banging around and it stinks like
dead bodies hmm I wonder what could be
going on in there yeah what the [ __ ]
else could that be come on so um so the
manager to his credit I guess actually
did go to Jeffrey Dahmer's apartment and
be like hey what's the deal with your
stinky ass apartment and Jeffrey Dahmer
said oh my freezer broke and all the
food spoiled and also he had like a big
tank of tropical fish and he's like oh a
bunch of my fish died
so that's probably what you know you're
just smelling all of that together and
the manager apparently bought it so
Jeffrey said yeah I'll take care of it
I'll get it all cleaned up and
everything like that sorry about that
now this right here is probably the most
famous thing and this is what pisses me
off the most
so May 26 1991 Jeffrey Dahmer comes
across a 14 year old boy
and I know I'm probably gonna pronounce
this poor kid's name wrong he's Laotian
his name's Conor accent that's Cynthia
'some phone
weirdly this kid and Jeffrey Dahmer
didn't mean to do this or anything like
that
this kid was the younger brother of a
guy that Jeffrey had been arrested for
molesting 3 years earlier like he didn't
realize that that's that they were
related but yeah the first kid he didn't
kill that kid he's just like molested
and then he got arrested but yeah so he
picks up this kid who's 14 and you know
says they give him money for pose for
photographs now the kid was initially
like oh man I don't know this doesn't
sound like legit but then he's like well
okay I guess I need the money or
whatever so the kid poses for two
pictures not completely naked he saw an
underwear on and stuff but then Jeffrey
drugged him and then started performing
oral sex on him now he also drills a
hole in the kid's skull and puts
hydrochloric acid into the brain now the
kid is still kind of walking around but
he's you know not right yeah so Jeffrey
like takes him into the bedroom in the
bedroom is stilt like a dead body for
like his former victim is still in there
like laying on the bed damn now Jeffrey
told the cops later he's like I think
I'm pretty sure that the kids saw the
dead body laying there since it was just
laying there big his life he's like but
you know the kid was kind of messed up
so I guess he didn't really realize what
was going on so yeah the guy this body
had been there for like three days so
and it was like all bloated and [ __ ]
mm-hmm yeah
so then the kid like goes unconscious
like from all the drugs and the [ __ ]
hole in his head and whatnot so then
Jeffrey like starts he lays down next to
the kid because that was the thing like
he just liked to lay down next to like
unconscious people he didn't want any
needy sexual [ __ ] yeah that's what I
mean there's a weird thing you know I
remember reading about the guy a long
time ago and you didn't really point
this out yet
Dahmer like to get up in a booty but he
didn't like anybody getting up in his
booty it was yeah it was too taxing for
him you don't talk yeah he was not a
power bottom thing is you say so this is
kind of fueling his need to kill dudes
yeah cuz he didn't want to have to
satisfy him
yeah weird up some weird [ __ ] if you ask
me yeah man well it's some real weird
[ __ ] if you're gay you might as well
just go ahead and be gay yeah yeah this
guy was just messed up alright yeah you
know what I mean
it's just messed up all around yes so he
lays next to this unconscious kid and
then he decides oh well I'm out of booze
so I'm just gonna leave the kid there
and then he goes down and Blake drinks
at a bar and goes so like buy some more
beer or whatever and while he's out the
kid wakes up and wanders out of the
apartment and like out into the street
he's naked
he has a hole in his head yeah his ass
is bleeding yeah and he's completely
like [ __ ] disoriented yeah he's
walking around out there sees three
women like from the neighborhood they
find him and they're like oh my god this
poor kid yeah they call 9-1-1 the kid
couldn't speak English I guess or
couldn't speak enough English for them
to like figure out what had happened so
the you know the 3-burner like okay it's
okay we'll call the could we called the
cops and we stayed here so Jeffrey
Dahmer comes back like before like from
the you know liquor store or whatever
before the cops get there
and he starts trying to like lead the
kid back to his apartment so you know
this is my friend everything's fine and
then we're like yeah no I don't think so
the cops are coming so the cops show up
these two [ __ ] cops and Jeffrey
Dahmer neat as you please he just says
oh this is my 19 year old boyfriend
the kid was 14
is my 19 year old boyfriend he's just
drank too much we had a big fight and he
gets like this one who's drunk he's just
like wanders around outside and you know
it's it's no big it's fine nothing's
going on now the women are like this is
some [ __ ] right here but the cops
were like oh it's a domestics woman
those queers do with their weirdness we
don't want to get involved in it it
seemed like they had that kind of
attitude because like the women were
like trying to argue good look the
kitties like bleeding and [ __ ] like that
and the cops apparently told the women
to quote/unquote butt out yeah well they
were probably we're like what's between
gays that's what they thought it would
say oh it's a domestic just be you guys
don't need it involved if the kid was
clearly injured right clearly injured so
what so like I said Jeffrey Dahmer like
I said and I'm not saying this in an
admiring way but this is pretty [ __ ]
ballsy he has a dead body in his
apartment okay no you know and heads
buckets of dicks everything and he takes
the cops like to prove that this is his
19 year old lover and this is all
consensual he takes the cops into his
apartment
yeah and shows them the Polaroids that
he took of the kid earlier that looks
like the kid is posing like cuz he was
because he got paid he's like yeah see
look I just took these like you know
just a few hours ago and we just were
hanging out and he drank too much and
everything's fine the cops noticed a bad
smell I think one of them even kind of
peeked into the bedroom and saw him but
didn't really see anything cuz the body
was like on the bed I don't know if it
was covered with a sheet or anything but
they said they did notice that it was
kind of stinky in there but again they
didn't put two and two together these
are like the most incompetent cops like
in the history of cops I don't know I
think I think what it is is that they
just assumed that Dahmer was a
[ __ ] who gave a [ __ ] yeah I mean
yeah I guess you would think that if you
had all that going on inside your
apartment the last thing you do is bring
cops to that damn apart the first thing
you know what I thought of I thought of
the tell-tale heart yeah all right where
he were he cut he he killed that old guy
and then cut the yeah he cut him up and
put him under the floorboards and then
he invited King he thought he was all
cocky so he invites the cops in there
and he's like I put the chairs right
top where I buried the body because he
thought he was like so slick and
everything cops are just sucking like
this is stinky [ __ ] and you know
I mean all these gays and [ __ ] like that
okay it's between them let's get the
[ __ ] out of here
that's basically what they said and I
see around them when they talk to them
later um they actually did get suspended
after this but I think they were able to
get their jobs back they got fired for a
little while but then they got their
jobs they unfortunately because it was
like a huge outcry like after that but I
think one of the cops said that I don't
think he even thought it smelled like
dead bodies he thought it just smelled
like [ __ ] which I'm like [ __ ] and dead
bodies do not smell the same well maybe
he's thinking well they were doing each
other up in a bootie and this was maybe
that maybe that's what yeah and then his
brain just went to that and it
interpreted as - like you know I mean
these gay dudes are always up in each
other's boys and [ __ ] it's gonna smell
bad in here nasty-ass gays that's what
he's thinking that's kind of I feel like
that was kind of that and they're kind
of disgusting like mess get out here
yeah I that's that's the vibe that I got
probably that they were just like oh
these you know these are weird gay
people and they're doing their weird gay
people thing and we don't want anything
to do with it's probably so he basically
just said yeah just take care of that
boy and then they just took off Yeah
right they didn't run a background check
on Dahmer which they would have seen
that he was a registered sex offender
had they checked that but they did not
they the cops took this kid back to the
house and guess what
Dahmer killed him yep yeah that's that's
the problem that the cops made right
there they should have [ __ ] done
right check on that dude yep see who he
would have taken five minutes have they
done that life red flags would have gone
up yep even so hold on you could sit
right here I'm not going you're not
gonna check something anyway they're
looking you find that dead body you're
like [ __ ] freeze yeah I mean
because like I said when they went in
there later there was [ __ ] he didn't
hide anything there was [ __ ] everywhere
no [ __ ] there was like body parts in his
fridge like just sitting on then on his
bedroom [ __ ] their skulls just on his
[ __ ] dresser and [ __ ] yeah yeah but
well he's talking about that [ __ ] now if
you've ever hunted deer dressing deer
and cleaning deer it smells like deer
[ __ ] deer [ __ ] just smells like grass
yeah man it doesn't smell all that bad
the guts sometimes the guy
smell kind of [ __ ] bad but it's just
the gaseous you know I mean look and it
comes out of the guts when you're
removing the internal organs I can
imagine how much worse it smells it
coming out of human being yeah you talk
about farts worse well worse I would
think so much worse yeah yeah but that's
the smell so that's what you smell and
you smell and all that dismemberment and
disemboweling yeah that's me smelling
because yeah it's like I couldn't
imagine you know the ideas part is those
guts really once the guts are out of any
body a deer or anything like that it's
light yeah it's not as heavy as it was
because you know when I guess a lot of
that he threw in that big acid VAT yeah
and that's a [ __ ] piss poor way of
doing it well you can tell the dude had
no [ __ ] background in field craft
yeah I mean once the guts are out most
of the smells gone of any animal yeah
you put that in a plastic bag you'd do
the same thing hunters to be put in a
plastic bag and you could dump it out in
a [ __ ] in an area where there are
animals and animals come and get it they
eat it well yeah it won't be there for
[ __ ] four hours if you [ __ ] them put
that [ __ ] out at sundown when Sun up
it'll all be gone yeah well yeah in
nature does it suck in deal yeah alright
so but you know he's probably he doesn't
want to drive that far out of town I
guess well yeah he's kind of in the
middle of the city I mean yeah I mean
and he's in an apartment for Christ's
sake yeah he's just like it's some of
this stuff um yeah I don't know if he
did this more than once but I know in at
least one case that he dissolved a lot
of the [ __ ] in that in acid and then
flushed it down the toilet once the guts
are out man decomposition slows down a
lot yeah I mean when you feel dressed in
the field deer so they don't spoil you
know they don't spoil yeah you're gonna
take them back earlier that day but you
know I'm in [ __ ] they're not gonna
spoil you don't want to leave us leave
something there cuz there's so much
bacteria yeah in the guts and all those
you know I mean it just ray dries
quickly get some ballade it's a lot
better so this guy you know not only is
he's a [ __ ] bag he's a [ __ ] murderer
he's also unsanitary that's not you say
I'm like how dirty were this dude's like
fingernail yeah he's very honest
I mean because he's cutting up human
bodies like in his [ __ ] bathtub and
you know he's not like [ __ ]
Washington now and why would you [ __ ]
put that in a and he worked in a
chocolate factory you think of it Hermey
ass [ __ ] fingers why would you put
that in acid bath that would smell even
worse I guess it didn't but it didn't
seem to bother here my guys just put all
that [ __ ] a bath tub you rinse it all
off and then you cubed that up with a
damn butcher knife on a cutting mat on a
cutting [ __ ] board right there in the
bathroom and make little giblets out of
it you could probably slowly flood flush
it all down toilet feels small enough I
don't think your problem you know it
have to be pretty small yeah other way
than other you know yeah otherwise you
getting like a [ __ ] Milson situation
but you know I mean I'm a cook too yeah
put that [ __ ] up on a [ __ ] cutting
montina Duden Duden I sell julienne on
that [ __ ] you know talking about well if
he would have just eaten the whole
bodies he might have got away with it
because it won't have been the lungs and
[ __ ] there's nothing it's terrible lungs
and guts I don't like getting that she
had [ __ ] stomachs I don't like any
that [ __ ] [ __ ] stinks to cook it
everything the only thing in it he I'm
thinking what only thing in a human that
I would find edible you know I mean not
only humans but I'm just be a heart and
a heart isn't that big but I love all
kinds of animal hearts like beef hearts
chicken hearts I don't like those
internal organs you know yeah there may
be white I'm not maybe white but I'm not
British those British people can [ __ ]
eat kidneys and [ __ ] yeah Billy yeah
ain't everything god no I'll get that
[ __ ] away from me everything but the
squeal and misses even in Mississippi
the poorest state in the Union okay
dollar for dollar Mississippi is a poor
state in the Union they don't eat that
[ __ ] that's called eatin low on the hog
very low nobody wants it most of Turtle
organs are thrown away yeah except the
heart maybe liver but you have to know
what to do with that
don't they make I mean don't they make
pet food out of some of it yeah it comes
out of slaughterhouses yeah there's a
lot of stuff you can do with all that
yeah people think that that all goes
into potted meat and stuff not really no
I know it does most air stuff actually
goes into dog food
other applications yeah but yeah so this
pork and like I said the cops are just
like
yeah you guys just keep on doing what
you're doing obviously nothing nefarious
is going on at all so this poor 14 year
old kid goes gets put back in the
apartment and Dahmer injects him in the
head again with hydrochloric acid and
this time it kills him
he actually Dahmer called in sick to
work the next day Jo soon he could have
the whole day to dismember the victim
yeah there was like a big day for him
right but the thing is he kept doing
that and eventually he got suspended and
then he got fired because he kept
killing people and probably was like
what about the head sick to the head and
he brought the head in from the locker
already yeah he had yeah he had that
Rick and um in like a filing cabinet
okay so he brought that home already
yeah it's not in his job anymore it was
there he yeah it was there for like a
year I think or like almost a year in
his work Locker and then when he moved
to this apartment he brought it and then
he kept it in there like a file drawer
so June 30th Dahmer goes to Chicago and
runs into a 20 year old guy named Matt
Turner at the bus station he says hey
want to come back to Milwaukee and I'll
give you all this money for a photo
shoot and [ __ ] like that so Matt says
okay so again he drugs the guy strangles
him and cut him up and he had the his
head and internal organs he put them in
plastic bags and put them in the freezer
this guy was actually never reported
missing so I don't know if he just
didn't have family that was looking for
him or whatever
five days after that he lures yet
another guy 23 year old Jeremiah
Weinberger from a bar and again drugged
him injected boiling water into his
brain and it put him in a coma and he
died two days later a few days after
that
July 15th the last one was July 5th so
this was ten days before I thought I was
working for that coma he's like it
worked
yeah oh yeah work all right I'm John bad
he's gonna feed the kid into intervening
sleeve aeneas Lee how much gonna bad
yeah and I put him in diapers what he
wasn't screwing yeah and then cleaning
him up before he'd have sex with him and
that's the probably he had planned
probably living sex doll yeah why don't
you just mind if I don't that's all
it was the 90s you know nowadays you can
just you can buy one that's almost like
real
yeah the first good real good sex doll I
ever saw was on the Howard Stern Show
it's called that real doll yeah and
there were several thousand dollars back
there and that must have been what 97
yeah yeah there's a broke-ass Dahmer
couldn't afford some [ __ ] they're a
little uncanny valley but they are you
know they are a lot better than those
was it just like it's inflatable well
that [ __ ] looks like a corpse to me baby
that's what I mean they're really light
of that they're creepy look if I was
gonna have something like that I'd want
to look like cartoon characters and
bright colors look it's better to make
it look like not a goddamn [ __ ] you
know talking about something is
entertaining yeah it doesn't look like
he's like a robot [ __ ] like a robot
chick yeah something like lights up yes
that kind of stuff
well yeah cuz if you're you can never
get it exactly looking like everybody
writes and murders doesn't go with the
guy so just go the total opposite we're
actually with the opposite direction
make it look like Betty Boop er so like
one of those robot chicks off of
sergeant Pepper's murder that [ __ ]
movie yeah like that shiny black [ __ ]
obviously robot chicks about that it's
just something like that I unabashedly
love that movie is the world's longest
music video yeah it was it was read I
love Jesus I want to see it again
actually I said a million times I was
growing up I know it's terrible but I
still love it
so July 15th he finds his next victim
who is 24 year old Oliver Lacy asked me
to pose nude for photographs and they
have sex and then he drugged him now
this one he's trying out more things
he's like I wanted to keep him alive for
longer so he tried to knock him out with
chloroform and again he calls in - he
calls in sick to work because he's like
oh I want to spend all day with this guy
like you know just unconscious so he can
do things to him just while he's
unconscious and not dead
so work says yeah sure you can have a
sick day but then they suspended him
right yeah so he kept him like
unconscious for a day or two and then he
strangled him had sex with the dead body
thank
cut it up he put his head and heart in
the fridge and skeleton in the freezer
again four days later he got fired from
his job he didn't care he had all those
body parts all probably not it's like
all that food yeah it's working he's got
all this fun to have in his own
apartment you know this is some [ __ ]
yeah so he so that's it at this point I
mean he's killing somebody like every
few days so like he finds out he gets
fired then he goes and finds another
victim a 25 year old guy named Joseph
Breda HOF he strangled that guy he left
the guy on the bed like he put like a
couple of sheets over him and he left
the body just laying there I'm assuming
he was sleeping next to it I mean I
think so he leaves the body there for
two days he moves the sheets and then
the head is has maggots all over it and
he's like well [ __ ] I wanted to keep
that so he actually like cuts the head
off and then he goes like cleans it and
puts it in the fridge and then like he
like he kept the torso as well like some
of the other body parts and like [ __ ]
he's just he's keeping all the [ __ ] in
the freezer and like keeping all oh [ __ ]
in house so now right here is uh where
his undoing have started to happen
yeah mother's life spinning out of
control he can't hold a job yeah and
it's just like I said and the killings
are just like only like a week or even
less than a week apart at this stage he
was just going oh he was just going on
what yeah so July 22nd 1991 so Geoffrey
goes up to three guys and gives them the
whole hey pose for nude photographs peel
now only one of them takes him up on it
now this is a guy named Tracy Edwards
who was 32 so he's like yeah I'll come
with you and like we'll have some drinks
and hang out and take pictures or
whatever now as soon as Tracy walks into
the apartment he's like mmm it smells
really [ __ ] up in here yeah and he
noticed that there was like a bunch of
containers of hydrochloric acid on the
floor and he's like huh do one stupid
that's a little suspicious
you know he's under estimating his
victims yeah and they're all [ __ ]
dumb yeah so he's kind of like so what
hydrochloric acid there Jeffy and he's
like oh well I just use it to like clean
bricks or clean masonry or something
like that traces like yeah all right so
they're like so they're talking and
stuff and Jeff's like hey why don't you
turn around and look at my fish or
whatever and he's like why you got fish
or whatever and then he put handcuffs on
him and so but then he was like trying
to he got handcuffs on one like hand but
then he was trying to like cuff you know
both of his hands together and he
couldn't do it so then he's like we'll
come in the bedroom and pose for
pictures so Tracey's like okay fine and
he goes in there and he sees like a
bunch of he's got he noticed he's got
like a bunch of like pictures of naked
dudes on the wall or whatever he notices
that he's watching Exorcist 3 which it
turned out with one of his favorite
movies yeah we reviewed that not a movie
it is a good movie yeah but yeah Jeffrey
Dahmer's favorite movie that and Return
of the Jedi they said he would he watch
like scenes from that before he would go
out trolling for whatever reason trying
to get one with a force he well he
related to um Brad Dourif character and
Exorcist 3 like the possessed guy yes
the demon or whatever yeah aybe related
to that game so um Tracy also noticed
the 57 gallon drum in the corner and
that that's where the smell was coming
from yeah so at this point Jeff is like
he pulls a knife out and he threatens
him with it and he says look I'm gonna
take nude pictures of you whether you
like it or not
Tracy like tries to be like okay just
chill out dude I'm not going anywhere
and he starts like kind of taking his
shirt off it's like it's all fun
everybody just needs to calm down and
[ __ ] like that
so then he's kind of like trying to
placate him you know he's just kind of
like you know I'll stay here I'll hang
out with you it's fine
and so then Tracy said later that Jeff
that Jeff had like put a knife up to his
chest and then said I'm gonna eat your
heart or something like that he says to
him
so Tracy is like okay um I really have
to like just calm this dude down and
then I'm just gonna jump out the [ __ ]
window like when he's not looking so he
goes to the bathroom and then he's like
hey let's just go back out to the living
room it's cool
out there we'll just sit and drink a
beer and everything will be fine so they
go out there and so Tracy is like
watching Jeffrey to see like make sure
that he's not like looking at him and
apparently he sees that he kind of like
spaced out for a second he's like oh hey
I gotta go to the bathroom again and
when he got up he popped Jeff and
Jeffrey in the face like he punched him
in the face and then ran the [ __ ] out of
the apartment so he so he actually kind
of got out so he runs out in the street
this is like 11:30 at night he runs down
the street he finds two cops and they
see the handcuff and he's like yeah he's
like I was just in this freaks apartment
and he put this [ __ ] handcuff on me
and there's all kind of like weird [ __ ]
in there so the cops like try to remove
it but the key they have like doesn't
fit it so they're like well why don't
you take us back to where this
quote-unquote freak lives
so Tracy takes them back to the
apartment now I should note before we
kind of get into this that Tracy Edwards
this poor guy he went through this
horrible ordeal and apparently he was
never right again after this like he had
like a lot of he was all homeless and he
had a lot of drug problems and stuff in
2011 he was arrested for murder because
him and another guy who was also
homeless they they got in a fight with a
third guy a friend there's another
homeless guy and they threw him off a
bridge and drowned him so yeah he got he
only got sentenced to 18 months though
because I guess I don't it is hard in it
it was like second-degree murder and the
other guy was there too and you know
they hadn't really you know well look at
this you're fighting with a guy you
throw him off a bridge that doesn't
necessarily mean you're trying to kill
him
yeah and then what they said because I
think either him or the other guy like
actually did try to go in there and like
get him out they didn't know that he
couldn't swim and show you don't know
how far it was it might have not been
far it might have been 12 foot drop yeah
in six foot of water if a dude can't
[ __ ] drown you know he's [ __ ]
trapped you know they can jump me there
you go yeah that's not murder that's why
you're gonna get 18 yeah so he got 18
months I was in 2012 I don't know what
happened to him after that but like I
said he didn't accident he didn't do so
well after escaping from Jeffrey Dahmer
I'm just he probably wouldn't do well
before that probably not because I think
he was working as a prostitute well yeah
he didn't get [ __ ] murder
it's just you know you gotta have that
so he takes three cops back to the
apartment now Jeffrey Dahmer like I said
it's he does not seem to care at all he
invites all of the cops and the guy back
into the apartment and he's like yeah
I've got the keys to the handcuffs he's
like yeah I put the handcuffs on there
although he didn't say why um he said
that at this point like Tracy told them
yeah he also pulled a knife on me and
said he was gonna eat my heart or
whatever and Jeffrey was like yeah
whatever he didn't like say anything
about that and then he's like I have the
key to those they're in my bedroom
drawer like in the dresser or whatever
so he started to go in there and get the
key but then the cop was like nah we're
gonna go in there and in there and get
it so one of the cops goes in the
bedroom to get the key and sees that
there's like a big-ass knife like
underneath the bed and he's like oh well
that must be the knife that he you know
brandished at Tracy Edwards he also saw
an open dresser drawer that had a whole
bunch of Polaroids in it so he's like
wonder what these could be uh I bet you
some of those are dead bodies they were
yeah seventy-four Polaroids
most of them showing bodies in various
stages of dismemberment [ __ ] that cot
shake but yeah cop [ __ ] his [ __ ]
pants yeah so basically he's looking at
the pictures going holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
good work but yeah so he walks out to
the other cop and he shows them to him
he's like I think these are real yeah so
um Jeffrey sees that they have his
pictures and then he started like trying
to fight the cops but there were two of
them and they overpowered him even
though he's a fairly large dude but you
know so they cuffed him and got a second
squad car to come for backup then one of
the cops goes into the kitchen and opens
the refrigerator and they find a severed
head on the bottom shelf damn next to
the cake probably [ __ ] out yeah and
then both of the cops said that when
they like had Jeffrey in the ground and
they had him like all cocked and
everything that he said for what I did I
should be dead that's what he said so
they do a search the apartment they end
up finding four severed head
in the kitchen seven sculls most of
which had been bleached a few of which
had been painted or decorated they also
found a bunch of blood drippings in a
tray in the bottom of the refrigerator
to human hearts part of our muscle was
he eaten those hearts I think he was or
he was eaten like some of the other
flesh I know for sure because they were
like in plastic bags in the tons you
guys had never had heart go down and get
some down not human all right
chicken hearts salted salted and [ __ ]
barbecue [ __ ] awesome not with sauce
just over [ __ ] over fire bastard like
shots Korea style Brazilian style
[ __ ] fantastic yeah yeah same thing
with [ __ ] beef heart man it's good
not fan it's the only internal organ I
really kind of like I couldn't I can
stand
liver if it's done right I don't mind if
it's mix it like when you make like
giblet gravy and stuff like that I would
prefer it without liver it just because
it has that strong taste but I can still
eat it it doesn't really it's good
breaded and fried with the right stuff
you know yeah my grandma's thin slice is
good it's good is it [ __ ] up that
we're talking about like recipes and
[ __ ] about what he was eating that [ __ ]
he was at with a human you know I'm
gonna say human tastes like pork so it's
probably called Pig yes probably the
heart and the liver would probably taste
kind of like a pride tastes like beef
heart and beef liver really cuz I don't
think he eat pork heart and pork liver
I'm eating pork internal organs I think
it's kind of risky although they do eat
that menudo which is stomach pork
stomach or guts I wouldn't do it man
what pigs eat I mean a normal farm pig
today I mean you got you got for my
Muslim brothers out there let me tell
you something the pig that Mohammed was
talking about it does not exist anymore
they're not in thighs they're in [ __ ]
on concrete they got water when a pig
gets hot it'll just [ __ ] [ __ ] and
piss on the ground and try to make a mud
hole to get into to cool off because
they can't sweat yeah that's not how
they are on farms they're more like
boars
you know I mean they have water to go
into the guy
they're clean and they're being fed just
corn and you know pieces of chicken and
stuff the other stuff that came out of
the farm that they're not gonna eat so
they're not eating the same crappy [ __ ]
and what is it trichinosis has been
totally eliminated from from American
pork population you can eat raw pork
here it's safe it's been wiped out yeah
because even like well [ __ ] even we've
seen like on I think is gordon ramsay
gordon ramsay said yes where where you
can eat pork it's like it's not raw but
it's like rare rare yeah now you can you
couldn't back in my grandparents to know
and and that's i think that's where a
lot of the [ __ ] carried over my it's
like yeah it wasn't safe to eat back
then my grandparents my grandpa my
grandmother would [ __ ] you know
mississippi woman would overcook pork
yeah cook the [ __ ] so much pork was
[ __ ] terrible yes because that's how
they learned how to cook pork because it
was dangerous back then yeah because you
had to cook the [ __ ] out of it to make
sure that there weren't any like [ __ ]
parasite the parasite the parasite is
trig enosis yeah isn't it yeah well
that's why that causes a yeah yeah trig
enosis
and that's been totally eliminated from
american pork at pigs it's not around
anymore
yeah you can eat that [ __ ] medium-rare
it's nice if you never cook it
everything like i said and i mean will
[ __ ] a steak i can you just run a match
under that and all [ __ ] yeah that's
relatively safe though yeah that's
always been safe yeah i'll [ __ ] love
beef I've eaten rare meet my old are
life yeah and I never had anything yeah
a lot of people can't stand it that's
weird the Chinese overcooked that [ __ ]
they think it's like when it's over done
it's just so yucky like I can see how
people you know um would want it like
medium rare so like I like like rare
rare you know lot of black dudes I knew
man they were like [ __ ] no we know
how y'all are I want that [ __ ] well done
yeah I need it well done it's just so
dry I mean let me tell you something man
it's it doesn't have any flavor it's
like it's leeches all asleep rare and
medium rare it is cooked it's just not
it's just not Bryant it's not cooked
towards brown it's good it's not raw
it's cooked yeah but still pink and you
get some that natural as you that
natural [ __ ] juices come out of there
that [ __ ] beautiful that's blood
don't worry about it you
cooked yeah it's fine I like it read in
the middle yeah it's good
I even like burgers like that make me
hungry
and like I said it's really [ __ ] up I
was different
what's the Jeffrey Dahmer so we're
talking about [ __ ] rare meeting [ __ ]
Dahmer was unsanitary he didn't know how
to dress anything so he couldn't butcher
he had [ __ ] zero knife skills for
what you know he didn't know how to
handle [ __ ] food I wouldn't eat
behind that [ __ ] not at all well
especially not because he's dealing with
human bodies I don't understand how he
ate that I don't know I don't understand
how he hate that and not you know I mean
that's [ __ ] filthy the way he's
handling this those bodies yeah I'm not
really sure how you could give me a deer
and I will turn that into a beautiful
foods food just that you could rap and
sell at the damn grocery store and get
all kinds of Mac and render a deer down
into that within about an hour inside a
house and not leave a drop of blood and
no spell so I don't know what this
[ __ ] was doing well like I said he's
probably not thinking about it cuz it's
dirty real killer
yeah dirty [ __ ] yeah so yeah so
they found all this [ __ ] in his [ __ ]
house also they found an entire torso in
his freezer a bag of human organs and
also little pieces of skin that was
stuck to the ice on the bottom which is
nice yeah they also found two entire
skeletons which he was gonna use for his
altar that he was planning a couple
severed hands saw a picture that it's
pretty special and what's up with this
chainsaw action he's using a chainsaw to
cook to cut him up sometimes I could cut
like I said I could take an animal the
size of a cow
and with a [ __ ] regular knife you
know I mean a six-inch knife turned that
into a bunch of steaks what the hell he
did a chainsaw for I don't know this
dude didn't didn't have any [ __ ]
skills well like I said he's not worried
about Paleolithic ancient man used to
take just [ __ ] obsidian blades pieces
of black volcanic glass sharp his [ __ ]
just the size of a damn quarter and
[ __ ] they could take a whole elephant
and turn that into food you know I mean
just four or five guys with little
pieces little
sharp pieces of glass you don't need
chainsaws yeah well just make a mess
maybe you like chainsaws yeah maybe so
they found some preserved penises as we
said mummified Skagen yes I got bag of
dicks but in a bit but in a bucket
bucket of dicks and the 57 gallon drum
had three dismembered torsos which were
dissolving in the acid as I mentioned
they also found 74 polaroid pictures of
bodies and various stages of
dismemberment so they arrest him and
like I said he immediately spills his
guts yeah Bergkamp stood upon they
interviewed him for 60 hours and he very
read he's like yeah I killed 16 dudes oh
and by the way I also killed another guy
like back and you know back in Ohio
first victim so they actually did end up
going back to Ohio and like checking
that old house and they did find they
didn't find the body because he had
gotten rid of most of it but they did
find enough bone fragments to be able to
identify him as Steven Hicks so you know
as I said he was completely forthcoming
just like yeah I had sex with the dead
bodies he had cut him up yeah I ate most
of them you know he just he didn't care
he's just like [ __ ] told them um he
said that when they interviewed him one
of his quotes was because they said you
know the past two months like before he
got caught that he got quote-unquote
completely swept along in his
compulsions he said it was an incessant
and never-ending desire to be with
someone at whatever cost someone
good-looking really nice-looking it just
filled my thoughts all day long and then
he told them about the altar that he was
planning on making he had made like a
little sketch of it it was like a little
line of skulls it's a shitty drawing
because he couldn't draw but like it was
like this all these little skulls and he
was gonna have a scale and a whole
skeleton on either side and it was gonna
be black like a black thing over the
like tablecloth over the table and it
was gonna have like a black leather
throne type thing with like some [ __ ]
blue lights and [ __ ] up there he had
like the whole thing planned out man
yeah yeah is like [ __ ] crazy
so he gets 1991
25th he got charged with four counts of
first-degree murder and then got charged
with the further 11 murders and again
they had gone to Ohio to the house where
he had previously lived and they found
bone fragments you know enough to
identify his first victim so they did
not charge him with the attempted murder
that he got caught for like Tracy
Edwards and they didn't charge him with
the murder of Stephen - Oh me because
since he claimed that he didn't remember
it and there was no physical evidence
remaining they thought that they only
wanted to go with the cases that they
had evidence of that they found the
bodies in his house and and he
remembered doing it and he confessed who
and everything like that so like I said
he confessed to everything he just like
pled guilty he actually ended up
pleading guilty but insane and that's
kind of went because they find a bucket
of dicks and severed heads and [ __ ] like
that in your house but you might we
thank you pretty much I mean that's the
only defense you have and you confessed
also yes I did this yes I had sex with
the bodies like that [ __ ] right so
that's kind of like the only angle you
can come at it from that he was insane
however he was um analyzed by several
psychologists psychiatrists a lot of
experts and stuff like that
who said that while he had obviously
some severe mental problems some severe
paraphilias although some of them argued
that maybe it wasn't necrophilia because
he was working so hard to create a
zombie that maybe he wanted a living you
know victim but he was just using the
dead ones because he couldn't get the
living thing that he wanted so it's like
it wasn't true necrophilia even though
the opposite if it was like I said it
was like a substitute so some of them
did argue that he wasn't a true
necrophile in the sense that he was just
kind of using that as a stopgap until he
could figure out how to make like
essentially a living sex all so they
they also pointed out to that there like
one he did make an effort to not get
caught like you know by you know
pulverizing bones and like getting
trying to get
the body's putting him out in the trash
and stuff like that trying to dissolve
them also they pointed out that the fact
that he would get drunk before he did it
like to calm himself down or to like
psych himself up for it
they're like also he was clearly
planning the [ __ ] so it came across that
they're like obviously he has a lot of
mental problems however he did know what
he was doing was wrong therefore you
can't get an insanity that's pretty much
the only I mean as far as I know that's
federal law right that's the only way
you can get insanity is if you genuinely
did not know what you were doing was
wrong yeah and they determined that even
though he was very very messed up that
he did know he was doing something bad
you know what I mean I mean it's on the
jury but yeah so yeah so the the trial
of Blatt was about two weeks lasted
about two weeks now they did rule him
sane like I said because he did seem to
know right from wrong even though he was
suffering from various mental disorders
obsessive-compulsive
yes not really on the jury yeah yeah not
yet so he got the first two counts of
murder he got life in prison one life
imprisonment plus ten years the
remaining 13 counts he got mandatory
sentence of life life imprisonment post
70 years Wisconsin at the time did not
have the death penalty so he didn't get
that he actually I think they also
extradited him to Ohio briefly to stand
trial for the Steven Hicks murder that
was his first victim but that was just a
formality like he had already pled
guilty to a show like that so they just
went him out there and it took like 45
minutes and then they just brought him
back so he got 16 life sentences
essentially so they sent him to the
Columbia Correctional Institution for a
year he was actually placed in solitary
confinement for his own safety because
they thought that the other inmates
would [ __ ] him up which turned out to be
pretty accurate
so then he got transferred to another
unit and he was given like a work detail
like he would clean like the toilets
like for two hours a day or whatever
like the you know where all the toilet
block was he also supposedly became a
born-again Christian like a lot of them
do and apparently I guess his dad
started sending him like creationist
books I'm like a boy that's really gonna
help yeah but yeah so he got all into my
bed my bed that might help a
[ __ ] to believe in something
that much instantly yeah so yeah so he
soon he got all into religion and was
like doing [ __ ] with the you know the
prison chaplain or whatever now in July
of 1994 there was another inmate named
Osvaldo Dorothy and he tried to kill
Dahmer like he had a razor like stuck
into a toothbrush like a you know shave
and he tried to slash his throat however
he was unsuccessful Jeffrey Dahmer was
actually not injured yeah there was a
big competition that killed yeah there
was yeah and like I said they knew that
and that's why they put him in solitary
confinement for a year but after that
they had to put him in general pop so
you know anything now his it's weird
because his family like I said his dad
seemed like a pretty okay dude he him in
the stepmom and his biological mom they
didn't condone what he did they said cuz
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] up but they still
came and visited him and they said they
still loved him and everything like that
so they came and visited him all the
time like even though what he did was
[ __ ] up um and his mom said that she
talked to him on the phone a lot and
that he was just really you know even
with the stabbing thing it's like he
didn't fight he didn't do anything he
just would say stuff like I don't really
care what happens to me like he thought
he deserved to die for what he did which
you know yeah he did but um he seemed to
know that and it didn't bother him that
like other people were like attacking
itself it didn't bother him so famously
the morning of November 28th 1994 he's
going he leaves his cell to go on his
work detail he was with two other
inmates named Jess
Anderson and Christopher's Carver now
these three were left unsupervised in
the prison gym showers for about 20
minutes about 8:10 a.m. they found
Jeffrey Dahmer on the floor of the gym
bathroom suffering from head and facial
wounds
someone had bludgeoned him about the
head with a 20 inch meant metal bar and
smashed his head against the wall I
think it was the handle to the mop
squeegee right they said it was an iron
pipe yeah I think it was far very
quickly it was you know how you know how
in in a mop bucket you have the thing
when you put the mop inside the damn
thing that squeezes it all out yeah I
think it was the handle that came out of
that yeah I don't know if it was sadder
if it was somewhat out of shower which
is about 20 inches long yeah but he had
been beaten to death with that you know
what I didn't realize was that
Christopher's Carver the guy that did it
he killed that other inmate too that was
with him Anderson Jesse Anderson he
killed both of me beat both them to
death and he he Jeffrey Dahmer wasn't
killed outright he they just found him
in his head was all bashed in and they
took him to the hospital but he died a
couple days or he died that same day and
then Anderson also died from his wounds
like a couple days later
Christopher's Carver had actually been
he had committed a murder in 1990 and he
was serving a life sentence and he just
went and told them he's like yeah I
killed those two he said God told me to
hmm like fast that too yeah I mean
before yeah and he was already in there
for life so he didn't have anything to
lose yeah um he said God told me to do
it yeah um and said he hadn't really
planned it he just kind of like did it
and God told him to but then later on he
said that the two guys were picking on
him like they were poking him and he
just got like sick of it or something he
also said that everybody hated Jeffrey
Dahmer because Jeffrey Dahmer was like
really cocky about his crimes and he
would do [ __ ] like like the guy said
that he was unrepentant and that he
would do [ __ ] like he would take his
food and like arrange it to look like
human limbs and like spray ketchup on it
be like hey this
you guys I'm gonna eat you ha ha that
funny so like some of the like that guy
said that and like some of the inmates
said that and said like everybody hated
him because he was like creepy and did
[ __ ] like that all the time yeah so no
one was really all that sad that he died
I mean other than his mom like his mom
very famously like when in the media
after and said something like ok well
somebody bludgeoned image death is
everybody happy now and I guess I think
most of the victims families were like
yeah yeah we are yeah um you know you
know what I think I mean the guy
Christopher's Carver the guy that killed
him he did get another life sentence but
he was already in there for life so he
didn't really give a [ __ ] but yeah so
yeah he got beaten to death in jail now
there was a little bit of controversy
afterward because they were I mean the
[ __ ] apartment building that he lived
in they ended up having to tear it down
because of this stigma around it also
all of his stuff they were gonna auction
it off and then like this group got
together is like man we don't want
anybody like profiting off that or
anything like that so they like raised a
bunch of money to buy all this stuff and
then like destroy it like burn all of it
like all of his furniture and [ __ ] like
that so they did all that just they were
trying to like just wipe him off the
[ __ ] map you know so I think that his
dad might still be alive his mom died of
cancer back in 2000 but I think his his
dad and his stepmom are still alive damn
then put him in their 90's though and
yeah they gotta be pretty [ __ ] old
right yeah I bet you they know I would
think but I mean yeah his biological mom
died now his brother David apparently
changed his name and [ __ ] went
incognito and I can't say that I blame
the guy Jeffrey Dahmer kind of reminds
me I associated him with the time right
before I went into the Army yeah cuz I
remember when they caught his ass I was
listening to it on the radio of his hand
loading a bunch of 45 ACP and I don't
think I was just getting ready to go
down and [ __ ] talk to the recruiter
huh Yeah right that time it's [ __ ]
something else yeah this is look [ __ ]
crazy sir and like I said what the hell
is wrong with Wisconsin with all this
[ __ ] it doesn't seem it's weird
because
California and California seems to have
California seems to have a thing with
like these kind of sexual sadists type
like Ted Bundy type killers and [ __ ]
like that not obviously not because they
haven't promoted killers but yes free
killers that seems to be like a largely
California thing Wisconsin turned
Midwest cannibals well Midwest crimes
seem to be like really gruesome yeah ax
murders cannibal crimes like people
making [ __ ] out of dead bodies like what
the [ __ ] man Florida is just totally off
the [ __ ] wall well it's because I
think it's because Florida most people
are not from here it attracts people so
it attracts me because the weather's
nice and [ __ ] like that so I think might
be nice depends all yours well to me
it's hot as I don't yeah I don't like it
I'm just saying that most people think
the weather's nice if they grew up like
somewhere really cold so everybody comes
here from everywhere so you get like all
the crazy people from all of the dogs
they're all like congregating yeah like
I was born in Florida but I don't know
that many people that were most people
are from somewhere else so yeah I
definitely do think that it's kind of
like a magnet for wackos yeah that's for
sure California yeah well I get any
anywhere where anywhere where the
weather is kind of nice and warm or mild
or whatever and you get it like all
these people wanting to get out of the
cold California is now full it's not
attracting people the way he used to
when I was when I grew up in California
you know the main [ __ ] California was
a magnet well yeah the California the
70s reminds me this reminds me very much
of Florida now yeah you know I mean
where you got all these people come from
New York and everything well in Florida
is still relatively inexpensive yeah it
is now semi-rural I will say though that
the wages are low yeah in Florida yeah
um so but the majority the dollar goes
much for much further than it didn't say
like in Boston I was living a boss yeah
you know I mean it [ __ ] the cost of
living here it's [ __ ] pretty low it
is yeah yeah depending but like I said
the wages are low too depending on what
line of work you're in but Florida
reminds me a lot of California back in
its heyday
yeah yeah when when there were still
countries
I didn't still you know I mean
California's run down now I got half my
family there and that's where I'm from
yeah I mean it's too much [ __ ]
traffic yeah too much [ __ ] well I
feel like Marta is gonna be like that it
will be that little take about another
20 years probably if it is well just
even looking like I said we might have
brought this up before but it's like
where we live
used to be naturally fairly rural yeah
and in the last just we've lived here
for what eight nine years it's now
suburbs and now it's like suburb it's
like seriously there's houses everywhere
there's stores everywhere there's
restaurants everywhere and most of this
[ __ ] like 80% of the [ __ ] was not here
when we moved in yeah and it's all
expensive stuff
yeah it's all like big mansions yeah
Trump and his buddies have houses up the
street from here then all the football
the basketball players have street you
know right up here on [ __ ] Markham
woods and there's a bunch of like big
huge sprawling like horse farms yeah and
then they're sucking all these really
nice and closed communities here and
we're in one of them more than one of
the newer ones yeah and then I think
ours is 10 or 11 years old something
yeah and then out of nowhere we used to
feel like we were in the country and I
don't you know it did seem like that
they built like five more of these
things in this area it's just wrecking
right around here and then II started
putting [ __ ] streetlights and like
you know intersection lights yeah we
were like what yeah and then they built
a McDonald's and then they're building
this and that big some of that stuff was
there like I think that Walgreens was
there it was there and I think that
grocery store was there but like they
built start growing food there fast food
yeah they build all kind of fast food
they built all [ __ ] like a [ __ ] a
restaurants they just built yeah within
less what is that a mile away yeah I
think it's uh I think it's let me see I
walked it one time it might be I think
it's almost two miles yeah a mile and
three corn in their building that damn
freeway yeah and then you have on the
other side of it they're building a
[ __ ] freeway overpass
yeah they built a whole [ __ ] freeway
like maybe two or three miles from here
to come out here
yeah and that's mind-blowing compared to
remember two eight years ago we there
was nothing out we thought we were
isolated there was nothing out we
thought we were out here in [ __ ] we
felt like we had infiltrated the rich
people's territory there's like who we
live out here yeah in the exclusive area
nobody's out here out in the forest no
now we're down and then we're now in the
upper-middle class suburbs and
upper-class suburbs and there's just
[ __ ] everywhere they're building [ __ ]
every every [ __ ] where everywhere
yeah where there was nothing there's a
great [ __ ] restaurants and all kinds
of stuff like just [ __ ] right out
back here I mean in a way it's nice
because you know shit's there and you
can go to it and cuz I don't like I
don't really like living out in the
middle of nowhere like I said my mom and
my stepdad they live out in the middle
of Ocala National Forest and it's like
seems like a big pain in the ass cuz
it's like you have to drive really
really far to get anywhere and I don't
like that but I mean it's not it's not
too bad where we are it's still fairly
quiet it's Sandford out in that
direction you used to be together yeah
but now they're kicking all those poor
people out get the [ __ ] out of here it's
all becoming high income yeah yeah well
yeah they're like Reeve there yeah you
can't afford to live out here get [ __ ]
out of here that's what they're telling
a miss refurbishing refurbishing
everything on the downtown they're
[ __ ] building clubs out there [ __ ]
big table bought that [ __ ] bar out
there yeah friend of ours Bobby yeah
just right before the [ __ ] current
right first like a couple of months he
oh but he is so excited he's been
wanting to open a bar for a long time
yeah and it was doing really well yes
it's like then he had a close he's this
really [ __ ] funny big old [ __ ]
cool black dude that's a friend of ID we
call him big Tom well he's that we we
met him at I bar we known any years he
wanted me to manage that place for him
yeah but it was just like Tom man
[ __ ] does not man I'll give you 40
thousand I was like Tom man you don't
[ __ ] need me man we just did some
quick consulting lit for him how to
decorate yeah like we went there before
we before he opened and like gave him
ideas about yes he says he pictures he
goes you know you knew it Ross you're
right I didn't need you good we're both
Tom's
I mean Nike and [ __ ] me look big Tom
because he's real tall yeah big-time
taking money from foot ain't taking my
Tom [ __ ] knock that [ __ ] off man you
can run this [ __ ] and he's doing it yeah
but like I said it kind of sucked that
he had to close it yeah he has it he has
a package store license so like if you
want to buy booze you can go there buy
booze from you and he's got a bunch of
[ __ ] he's got a bunch of [ __ ] tire
shops yeah he's not yet he's got a whole
bunch of Tom back in the day at the club
[ __ ] Tom realized he could trust me
when he [ __ ] pulled out that big
[ __ ] wad of money tried to hand me
that might as a man put your [ __ ]
money away when you just denied when you
tell a man you don't have to pay him
then all of a sudden you know he trusts
you yeah there yeah him and his wife are
both super cold yeah and they're in
there yeah they got Toussaint that's
right yeah I just I just know that one
because he comes white hip-hop artists
yeah yeah yeah yeah super nice thing
like all right so you want to wrap up
the Jeffrey - oh sorry we went into the
cooking thing that is very tasteless oh
[ __ ] I did it again hope you guys
enjoyed this [ __ ] show about this
[ __ ]
yeah well he's dead so it's alright yeah
so uh remember if you like the show like
share subscribe on all your social media
if you'd like to financially support the
show would be much appreciated you go to
work what was I gonna say oh you can go
our patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
and there's a button in the sidebar that
goes to a PayPal account Murray can give
a one-time donation also remember to go
check follow us on Instagram I'm still
posting [ __ ] on there like once or twice
a day trying to keep that up and I'm
trying to get more followers so go over
there and do that if you have an
Instagram account and that'll do it for
episode 189 we will see you next time
bye
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]